[Music]
foreign
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
yeah
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud proud and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] em
[Music]
Eddie boy
Mike trouble just before I come on of
course of course on such a big day
can go wrong will go wrong isn't that
how it goes
isn't that just how let's talk about our
democracy for a minute
you see what I mean you see what I mean
yeah and it's crazy over here absolutely
crazy
welcome to the Tony Michaels podcast
it's arraignment day
New York City New York City is a little
uh spicy this morning it's getting spicy
in New York City I don't know if you've
seen this
um some of the videos that are out on
Twitter there yeah and everyone's uh um
saying what can go wrong will go wrong
of course it is it is it is arraignment
day so it does seem like everything's
gonna go right
what could be wrong
hell no baby what a great day to be
alive everyone thinks that the country
is aspiring into Peril uh we have
fascists in Tennessee trying to out and
oust the other party and oust any
opposition at all
um to uh to Freedom democracy to
protesting they're really upset the
three members
were were you know using their right to
protest
with gun rights Advocates as far excuse
me gun control Advocates against the the
absolute ridiculous gun laws in
Tennessee today today in democracy we
have in the Wisconsin Supreme Court
an election that could swing the control
of the Supreme Court from conservative
to uh I don't know just common sense
so we have that going on as well today
and in the big news today is Trump's
arraignment day now again folks
who gives a [__] about apparently these
are 34 felonies that's what we're
hearing is it's 34 felonies now we'll
know in a matter of a couple hours
probably of exactly what these felonies
consist of my guess is is that they're
going to unseal this indictment
just a little bit before his arraignment
for his attorneys to actually review it
we know what the plea is going to be in
the open and Raymond it's going to be
not guilty we know that
um is he going to have a mug shot
doesn't sound like it is he going to do
a DNA test doesn't sound like it uh last
late last night the judge
uh that is going to be holding the
arraignment will not allow cameras into
the courtroom now there will be official
record uh still shot cameras in the
courtroom apparently but that is about
it I think that's all the [__] we're
gonna get [__] but we are going
to have some sort of record of Donald
Trump being in the courtroom and being
arraigned
um now the perp walk doesn't seem like
we're gonna get handcuffs uh and
apparently it sounds like the
arraignment's gonna take place at 2 15.
so we'll actually be trying to cover
some of this stuff live we may go three
hours today uh so stay with us today if
you're if you're gonna if you're gonna
be anywhere you want to be here
because we'll stay with you we're gonna
have Texas Paul with us today as we do
on every Tuesday it's Taco Tuesday it's
Texas Paul Tuesday and it's felony
Tuesday Trump felony Tuesday folks this
isn't the last time he's gonna be
arraigned on felony charges though I
mean that's for sure there's no way that
this guy is skating on his other crimes
that he's committed I don't think so
maybe I'm [__] wrong but I believe
that Donald Trump
will continue to be indicted on other
federal charges and state charges one
being
in the state of Georgia which seems like
they're getting closer and so
hang on to your hats folks and
especially your cowboy hats because
Texas ball is going to join us at the
bottom of the hour now let's get to the
problem in Tennessee
let's get to the the problem in
Tennessee now you guys know in Nashville
at the Covenant School there was a
shooting that happened a person who
should not had a weapon of War had a
weapon of War walked into a school
murdered Cold Blood three children and
three teachers and every reason why is
because Republicans in Tennessee bowed
down to the NRA and they allow anyone
and everyone to over 21 to get a weapon
to carry weapon anywhere and everywhere
they want
that's the problem now over the last few
days in Tennessee There's Been huge
protests at the Capitol
of students young people and just
average everyday citizens demanding
demanding that the legislator there do
something to protect children in schools
like the three kids that were
slaughtered ripped apart
by weapons of war in the Covenant School
and yesterday the Republicans
were trying to expel three members of
the democratic caucus
because they were protesting with those
protesters now this is fascism folks
this is fascism and it's bear and
Essentials
when they're removing people who they
don't like their [__] beliefs they
don't like their political views they
don't like that they speak out against
their political views
this this is
bare fascism as it as it will be
continue to be on display with the
Republican Party
now there's no bigger fascist in this
country because we like to harp on the
House of Representatives which we have
our fair share of fascist in the House
of Representatives we have Marjorie
Taylor green which we'll get to some
news on that petty Yeti today we have
Jim Jordan Matt Getz
we have uh Lauren bobert Paul gozar Andy
Biggs Jim Comer I mean the list goes on
and on and on about all these fascists
that are in that are in the United
States House of Representatives we have
a lot of backstop to those but in these
red States
in these red States these legislators
are full of Marjorie Taylor greens
absolutely packed for Jim Jordans and
Jim comers
these [__] real America First Nazis
is where they're at I mean just give you
an example Ron DeSantis
in private in secret signed and opened
carry in Florida
with only the NRA present hmm I wonder
who he signed that bill for it wasn't
for the people he didn't allow the
people to see him sign that bill only
the people who lobbied to get them to
pass that legislation so that way the
gun lobby and the gun manufacturers can
sell anything and everything to anyone
they want in Florida damn children damn
citizens damn safety who gives a [__]
about lives they're not pro-life
in Missouri last week in Missouri
I mean they're they're not about they're
not about limiting and restricting gun
sales but they definitely don't want
libraries libraries are the thing that
are killing children by the way these
Mass libraries that have happened these
Mass book readings oh my God you talk
about a safety issue in the state of
Missouri
the state of Missouri took every single
[__] dollar every single [__]
dollar
out of the budget for public libraries
I I listen to me when I tell you this
the state of Missouri the Nazi
legislators in the state of Missouri
ripped every single [__] dollar
away from public libraries not not not
not libraries and high populated areas
this strips the libraries out of rural
communities which some in some cases in
some cases in rural areas this is their
only access to books or media in general
because they don't have the [__]
internet they will soon because
Democrats did that when they pass the
infrastructure Bill high-speed internet
is coming to those communities but
sometimes that's the only contact of
media that these people have in DVDs
movies documentaries books I don't know
magazines newspapers these people don't
have high-speed internet
the public libraries in the state of
Missouri are sometimes their only
[__] connection from their rural
community to the outside world
which I understand a lot of people in
these rural communities probably don't
want connection to the outside world and
the truth because they live in their own
little [__] worlds folks
they live in their own little worlds
they've created this white supremacy
buffer zone in this country they don't
live in reality they do not have a sense
of who the country is
it's only a parent
when these [__] morons think that
this country is going to be in shambles
because Donald Trump is indicted for
crimes he committed
this is only going to make our country
better this is only going to move
forward this nonsense and get rid of the
[__] that we are going through and
have been going through the last 15
[__] years to be quite honest a lot
of this stems from the racism that
sprung up when Barack Obama the black
guy became president oh my God where do
you think this came from where do you
think this stems from where do you think
the root cause is of this
it is white supremacy
white supremacy is the reason why
Republicans in Tennessee expel those
members white supremacy is the reason
why Missouri legislators stripped every
single [__] nickel from public
libraries in the state
the reason why people are even thinking
about protesting the president criminal
fraudster is because of white supremacy
he's white and they hate blacks he hates
blacks he [__] hates Muslims he hates
anyone who isn't him
and they keep going on and on and on
about how this is going to destroy our
country and we have a two-tier justice
system well God damn it's about time
they come around to knowing that there's
a two-tier [__] justice system in
this country
and what they're really scared of what
they're terrified of is that their
Tierra Justice is not going to protect
them anymore
that's what this is a signal of of
Donald Trump being held to account to
his mother [__] crimes
so buckle up folks
cause we are the jury we are the [__]
judge
and we will charge and convict Donald
Trump and we will send him [__]
packing Bet On It
it's gonna be a long hard slog to 2024
and boy is it going to get
more and more exciting every single
moment trust me
the worst is yet to come
to change the quote from a a crazy
person the worst is yet to come
and it's knocking at the door and we
must be vigilant
we cannot lose sight everyone keeps
saying oh stop stop talking about Trump
and talk about the Wisconsin Supreme
Court in Tennessee we can do all those
things all at the same time folks
we are capable
this is a democracy this is a this is a
constitutional Democratic Republic where
the people are the government
We the People
and we can do this this is not that hard
have you seen the competition
the headliner
the headliner to go protest the Trump
arraignment today was Marjorie hooffoot
green
she lasted about two [__] seconds
and whistles kill that fascism I don't
know if we've got whistles that we can
print uh this whistle kills fascism
um but I'm telling you the decent these
are real America First Nazis they are
apparently terrified this is their
Kryptonite whistles
whew she ran away from the whistles
which is hilarious
we're gonna show you this footage I got
a plenty of footage to show you and of
course we have a great guest today as
normal on Tuesdays we have Texas pods
Texas Paul Tuesday he's back from
vacation he's back in the fight he's
ready to swing I know he is and I know
he's gonna have he's gonna have plenty
analysis so he joins us today we're
trying to get our our correspondent on
the ground at the protest in New York
City on the broadcast today hopefully
hopefully we will have that person
I don't want to say exactly who it is
yet but hopefully we'll have that person
live on the ground
at the chaos in New York City now again
we're gonna stay live as long as you
guys stay here and and watch so we're
gonna try to go to three hours we'll see
if um if we can get footage there's
gonna be no cameras inside the courtroom
so we won't actually get footage of the
courtroom now that they're gonna take a
record and document records of the
courtroom so there will be pictures
apparently of him in the courtroom being
arraigned
um that's the only thing the judge is
going to allow is some of those still
photos now we will apparently will get
the him leaving Trump Tower I think
that's the plan
and then he's going to get out and get
into the courthouse and probably within
30 minutes of entering the courthouse
he'll probably leave it won't take long
to book him they're not going to do a
mug shot apparently they're not doing
DNA
so they're gonna escort him to the
booking room take his fingerprints uh
and then take him to the arraignment
where as long as they have everything in
order and chaos doesn't ensue will
probably only take less than 20 minutes
it won't take long to Iran you it'll
take longer to read how many felony
charges this [__] has it's
probably the longest part of the
arraignment
and and if they actually get the
arraignment ahead of time or excuse me
the indictments ahead of time
um they may forego their judge even
reading them out loud who knows this
could go so many ways
it could go but craziness is happening
in New York City uh right now there's
just as many counter protesters probably
more than there are protesters and you
should see
you should see the swell folks that that
showed up to support Donald Trump I
don't know if you've seen a trump rally
before a footage of a trump rally but
holy [__] the um
laugh
now the fringes of those rallies are the
ones who showed up in New York City I
just I don't believe that he gives a
[__] about these people right like when
you see pictures of these people who are
there in support of him there's no way
he would give them more than [__]
half a second of his thought or time
like I mean unless they were gonna give
him money right like I mean if they were
going to give him you know their their
[__] his their [__] equity in
their home they're gonna take out a loan
or their 401K hey he might spare a
second or two on he might
that's a strong might too right
but these these people are the people
that Donald Trump loves
like just from the look of them you know
who am I to judge I really don't give a
[__]
I mean honestly a lot of these people
are desecrating the American Flag by
wearing American flag clothes do I care
no I don't think that's I don't think
that's against anyone's right to
desecrate the American Flag by wearing
them as [__] clothing but these
people hell oh America America
patriotism and then they're wearing the
American flag as overalls or as a jacket
like do you even understand do you even
know what the hell gate well they don't
understand a lot
but the delusion is deep
and we're in the thick of it and we're
going to be breaking it down here on the
Tony Michaels podcast so I'm not going
to waste any time let's go to a break
when we come back if Texas Paul can give
me a thumbs up are you ready are you
ready Paul
are you ready
okay Texas Paul is ready let's go to a
break and we'll come right back with
Texas Paul because it's Tuesday right
after this don't go anywhere we'll be
right back
what the [__] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow Patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny we
know what you would do you'd reach out
and give that true American a hand now
here's your chance for only fifty
dollars a day you can help us help those
true Americans recover from Biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those Trump supporters and this is that
moment send your donation via venmo to
the real president Donald J Trump it's
only fifty dollars a day recurring and
it means you'll get these Trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime please donate now because
those Trump supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment where
back to the Tony Michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
I'm gonna wasting time today we're gonna
get right into it videos
[Music]
it is so we're gonna go to Texas Paul
Texas Paul welcome back to the Tony
Michaels podcast how was the vacation my
friend are you ready to are you ready to
start swinging on these flashes man it
was wonderful and hell yeah I'm glad to
be back man I am pumped let's do this
all right how do I look man how do I
look oh you look fantastic the Hat's
great the shirts I know I even make I I
even make covid look pretty
right now
oh God I knew that was gonna happen
traveling that seems to be the uh yeah
catch the vid that's why you need to be
safe and vaccinated and boosted and if
you don't like it vaccinated baby
that's right that's right that's right
um there's a lot of there's a lot of
news coming out of New York City and
we're going to get to some of these
Cliffs but I know this morning you were
making some cries for uh anyone to call
their relatives in Wisconsin I know a
lot of people been talking about the
Wisconsin Supreme Court race
um I frankly I'm very confident that um
we're gonna turn out a good vote there
and um the Good's gonna happen there
we're going to turn that court from what
we know as a conservative Court to more
of a common sense Court a court of the
people in Wisconsin I believe that's
what's going to drive people to the
polls and the reason why is because
they're tired of that Court making
really stupid [__] decisions and
there's someone on the ballot that has
common sense
um you know most people would call her a
liberal but she has common [__] sense
so tell us tell us a little bit about
that race before we get to New York City
I also want to touch a bid on Tennessee
as well
oh you got Jan you got Janet potassowitz
up there folks she is the bomb she has
been an ADA for 25 years she was a
circuit courts judge in Wisconsin for 25
years and you know they they of course
everybody that runs on the Democratic
ticket the Republican side to paint them
as the most crazy insane liberal commune
that ever ran but she's actually pretty
middle of the road she's she's super
sharp she's the most qualified person on
the ballot and she's running she's
running against Kelly
um this guy is
um you know Generac are you familiar
with Generac the the backup generators
and [__] like that the Kern family
founded that company he this guy uh was
appointed Kelly was appointed her
opponent Kelly was appointed to the
Supreme Court uh um in 2016 uh served a
partial term then lost his re-election
mid in 2020 because he's a total Jack
hole
um this get this guy really is I mean he
when he lost his term they'd give you an
idea what this guy is legally he went to
work for the Kern family running their
trust uh um you know doing being the
legal uh handling the legal work of
their trust
um he he is just a
everything you would imagine a [__] bag
sorry
nasty ass Republican would be he's the
guy that when the city of Milwaukee
tried to to ban firearms on their buses
um you know yeah Scott Walker doing
trying to do that we love guns and [__]
you know and and the City of Milwaukee
said well we don't would rather not have
shootouts on our buses so no guns on
buses it was Kelly that wrote the
majority opinion that told the city of
Milwaukee they didn't have the legal
authority to ban guns on their own buses
so this is the kind of [__] this is I
mean it's and and I know everything's
super important I mean we got Trump
getting indicted today the mimosas are
coming out I mean it's going to be a
good day and then you got all the [__]
that's going on in Tennessee
um all that crazy I know there's a lot
to pay attention to folks but man if
you've got people if you've got people
in Wisconsin call them call them get out
the vote in Wisconsin
even if you know they're already going
to vote still call them to make sure
that's Amen brother that's a very
important situation that we've got going
there
um so what and you know
the other the other problem that we have
is in Tennessee so we have a couple
state issues here now we have this mass
shooting at the Covenant School where
because Republicans bowed out to the NRA
and let anyone and anyone anyone and
everyone in the state of Tennessee
without checks or balances or anything
grab a weapon legally buy a weapon and
walk around the streets with a weapon
concealed or are open it doesn't matter
um that that's just the state of of
Tennessee right now now because these
three children were murdered in Cold
Blood with three teachers six people
killed that day
um from just again someone who had a gun
who I was able to gain access to these
guns through the laws that are that are
of the land or lack thereof more than
more than anything there in Tennessee
people started protesting at the Capitol
and they haven't let up this has been I
think day four or five
of mass protests there in um in
Tennessee now at first the right wing
tried to frame it up as an Insurrection
like a bunch of trans people all around
the country to go to Tennessee and to to
have an Insurrection on the capital well
they were they were seeing uh this
little white of mine is what the if
that's an Insurrection well excuse me
but um um it didn't deter the protesters
the protesters were not deterred by the
Insurrection talk even even the state
legislators in Tennessee the Republicans
um who are very extreme on some of these
issues were calling an Insurrection and
then yesterday well the other day uh
well you could tell you you know the
three legislators that we found to the
well they were speaking in the well
yes Justin Jones
um
um [__] want to lose me and and [__] I'm
having a mind lock right now it's Justin
Jones uh uh Justin
damn it I hate when that happens
somebody asked me a question and my mind
goes blank somebody help me out in the
chat you know those people well speaking
of Justin Jones I actually I actually
had the video yesterday uh well last
night uh of Lafferty actually pushing
him and grabs his phone uh on the floor
as they were voting to expel now there
were people in the chamber here you're
gonna hear them yelling and screaming
um and you're also you're also going to
hear
um
people trying to get them out because
they're trying to do a vote and they
won't let them hold the vote let's watch
this video
that's Lafferty
[Applause]
we see the protesters up
and there he hits him
um so that that that video came straight
from uh Justin Jones representative
there now he also made a video that kind
of went viral last night where he was
outside and he was talking about how
they were going to vote to expel these
members not only did they vote to expel
these members they took away their IDs
they took them off their committees
basically I mean they're no longer I
lost Texas ball there
um he'll be back
um let me see if I can find that video
of Justin Jones uh giving a plea for
I think I lost you there Texas ball yeah
I don't know what happened
uh yeah no problem
um we're some are saying your mic is too
loud but I think I got it fixed if
anyone if anyone thinks uh Paul's mic is
still too loud just let me know
um yeah that's that's cool that's cool
I've got um I've got a few uh let's see
let me let me go let me go to the
footage yesterday that viral video that
was going around of Justin uh Justin
Jones and then uh we'll try to get to
the
um chaos at hand in New York City
um because there is it's ongoing up
there here is um here's the video
yesterday of him uh outside the Capitol
Building there uh making the plea and
that the Republicans were going to try
to block them from being members of
Congress let's listen
um so what's going on here in Tennessee
today so three of us lawmakers who still
with our constituents demanding it they
take action and hear the thousands of
people gathered on Thursday talking
about the crisis of mass shootings
um where are we've been kicked off our
committees as Representatives elected by
our constitution each of us represents
78 000 people and our people are being
silenced because they're kicking us off
committees they're threatening to take a
vote to expel us today
um our member ID badges have been shut
off
um our representative ID badges have
been shut off
um and this is not what democracy looks
like you know we are elected to serve
our constituents and I'm the youngest
Democratic lawmaker here uh the most
diverse district and by shutting me down
they're showing down the voice of my
constituents um so this is one of my
constituents
shooting and so we're here to speak for
them and they won't even let us speak to
our people they wouldn't let us talk on
the floor they shut our microphones off
um they they shut our voting machines
off we couldn't even talk about the
issue and so when we went to the well to
force the issue they called us
insurrectionists and are now trying to
expel us from the legislature so this is
fascism and its best Texas ball no
question about it this is exactly what
um the Republicans want this is what
they're going to do they're going to
continue this uh [__] too all around the
country
um I was in a space the other day Texas
ball and they said we're going to get
revenge on you since you're going to
indict Donald Trump uh that that's
blatantly there were several of them
saying Republicans are going to get
revenge and and they're going to keep
coming at it they're going to keep
attacking democracy here and the reason
why is because they're orange Mussolini
Jesus is going down in flames
um they they've made him the Martyr and
he will be the Martyr of their party
which more power to them
um there is no indication that this
country doesn't the majority of this
country doesn't want him to be to pay
for his [__] crimes there's very few
people percentage-wise that don't want
him to pay for his crimes and and but
those folks have control in some of
these districts and some of these
legislators and they are going to seek
revenge on Democrats anywhere and
everywhere they can that is why some of
this legislation is just to own the libs
it has nothing to do with more than that
than to fight democracy and kill
democracy that's what they're trying to
do all around the country now as I
brought up earlier they're even wanting
to in Missouri they defunded every
single nickel every single penny of
Public Library funding and what's your
take on what's happening in Tennessee
because it seems it seems that the
Republican have jumped the shark from
um a reasonable gun debate about gun
safety in the state of Tennessee to full
on just showing their fascism right out
in the open and that they're willing to
use Fascism and protect the gun lobby
and gun manufacturers
yeah
well I you know I 100 what get what hit
me the most it was it was Justin Jones
Justin Pearson and Gloria Johnson I
believe
um
Gloria yeah it was Gloria Johnson
if you're calling what's happening in
Tennessee and Insurrection okay first
you've got to tell me what are they
trying to overturn
okay I mean you you look like a weak
freaking Namby pamby little I mean do we
dork I can't think of any more weakling
pejoratives to describe these these
Tennessee chicken shits they're just
you you've got to tell me if you're
going to call this an Insurrection what
election were they trying to overturn no
they were just saying see me
I am here [__] don't just see your
lobbyists we're your constituents see me
that's not an Insurrection that is
trying to get your attention
and the only violence we see is out of a
freaking Republican this jackass Justin
Lafferty and by the way my Tennessee
people why the hell is everybody named
Justin in your state
I don't know it must be the best you
know but you know I'm telling you man
I just I looked at these guys and I
listened to the [__] they said this is
these are kids these are kids
and they're out there saying look see me
this shooting [__] is real well it's
really happening don't just sit back and
take your [__] check
you know and and and these Republicans
are so pathetically weak
they are so pathetic it's just and I I
just I look at these guys and they're
like oh we're gonna kick three out to
good even okay [__] let's do this
we'll kick 30 [__] Republicans out
for no goddamn reason because believe me
we have the votes to do it in States
you know you guys think that you're the
only swinging dick in the room you're
not
you want to play this game we're going
to just kick the opposition party out
fine let's go down that road we'll do it
till you don't want to do it anymore I'm
telling you gerrymandering kicking
people out for no damn reason somebody
farts in the damn chamber that's an
assault you're kicked out you know I
mean I am tired I am tired of it I am
tired of it I'm sick and damn tired of
it all they do is this drama [__]
you know there there are real things
going on in this world Tony I mean real
things going on we have and and about
the whole shooting
that set this off I've been telling
Republicans forever you know you sit
there and you ignore it because it's a
new value and you're not in Uvalde well
guess how guess what it came home to
your kids this time
and you want to call it terrorism now oh
it's terrorism now
you know yeah it was it was [__]
terrorism Welcome to our world
Welcome to our world
you had somebody that you violated and
then told them Second Amendment
Solutions are are on the table
you know the thing that the confusing
narrative from the right from me is this
is that they keep saying that this is a
trans issue I mean obviously they want
to make it a transition right because
the person who who had the weapon who
the the state of Tennessee and
Republicans in the state of Tennessee
allowed to have these weapons with no
question no background check apparently
this person was under some sort of
[__]
um um psychological supervision or
something of that sort there's no red
flag laws they just want anyone and
everyone to have guns and carry whenever
whenever they can and wherever they can
now they're trying to make it into into
a gender issue which I don't even
understand that and they keep saying
they keep saying that somehow we're
trying to push and gender agenda like
what the [__] are you talking we we are
yelling and screaming at the top of our
lungs and these people are in the state
capitol saying it's the [__] guns
it's the guns dummy do something with
the guns stop talking about pronouns and
drag shows it's the [__] guns killing
people
killing students Killing Children
Killing our citizens you dumb
[__] it's the guns and they're
trying to spin it that we don't we're
not having a gun debate like what the
[__] are you talking about there are
thousands of people showing up at the
tennesseans showing up at the state
capitol demanding demanding that you
acknowledge that it's the guns that's
all they want they just they don't even
want you to take away guns from people
they just want you to have common sense
background checks red flags [__] that
will will just at least save a few
[__] lives from gun violence just a
few [__] lives we're not even asking
you to [__] take away the Second
Amendment or ban assault weapons they're
just wanting to save a few just a few
just a couple two three four maybe a
dozen lives in the state of Tennessee
they feel like thousands of them
marching
and these Representatives these state
legislators felt like going to the well
because they shut off their voting
machines and they shut off their mites
they felt like it was worth it for those
lives because they believe in protecting
life unlike the pro-life fake pro-life
[__] Republicans out there Paul I
we're gonna have to I and I want to keep
going on this Tennessee issue but we're
gonna have to go to New York
um we're gonna have to get to this
arraignment and some of the footage
because I'm gonna run out of time even
with three hours if we broadcast three
hours today but one thing I want to tell
the audience why you're here subscribe
to the YouTube channel while you're here
do not forget to subscribe we're going
to be on for three hours but you're not
going to want to miss any episode
tomorrow Texas fall tomorrow I have on
former Senator Doug Jones Doug Jones is
going to join me tomorrow he's going to
talk about the Democratic National
Convention coming to the South he's he's
in favor of Atlanta he wanted to come on
to tell me about that so I I said sure
absolutely let's have you on and I'm
gonna ask him about the Trump indictment
and the Trump statement that will be
made tonight so I'll get a senator a
former prosecutor and former Senator
Doug Jones of Alabama his response to
that tomorrow also tomorrow Dr Rachel
bittickoffer is going to join me as well
and she's going to talk about the
politics of what is going on all around
the country whether it's Wisconsin
Tennessee or the Trump indictment or in
Florida with guns or or Missouri with
the library she's going to come break
down the politics tomorrow and give you
the strategy that you need to keep going
and keep pushing this narrative because
it's up to us we are the jury folks we
are the jury in this country it is our
government so again don't forget to
subscribe to the Tony Michaels podcast
YouTube channel right here on YouTube
and download every single episode if you
can on Apple Spotify and Google okay my
Shameless plug is over let's go to
Grandpa Poopypants Texas Paul he is
freaking the [__] out and I'm out I wish
I would have popped some popcorn I
didn't have time this morning but here's
here's one of one of the best uh Broad
Social post he may this morning it's
he's got his cats locked on again
obviously he's a Cajun and one terrified
he says the radical left Democrats have
criminalized the justice system this is
what a this is not what America is
supposed to be
it's so funny when he's held to account
that that the justice system isn't
working right like it's just really
funny and this two-tier system they keep
talking about again I've said it once
I'll say it a million times the reason
why they keep talking about a two-tier
justice system is because they're
terrified that their tear that protects
them will no longer protect them after
this that's what they're really
terrified of is yes we do have a dude
dear justice system in this country it's
been like that for a long time a lot of
us have been woke to that idea we knew
that [__] and now now that you
[__] have woke up to a two-tier
justice system we see you we know why
you're acknowledging it because you're
scared that your tear will no longer
protect you what's your take on um
today's arraignment uh Texas Paul what
do you think do you have any predictions
or do you think there's going to be
anything out of the ordinary or what we
already know the guys are criminal these
are felony charges apparently all of
them not one misdemeanor is gonna be in
the this indictment
um and he's going to go in get a rain to
leave and go back to Mar-A-Lago and
tonight he's gonna probably break his
gag order that the judge is going to
give him today do you see anything
different from that that's going to
happen or is he just is he going to do
something unpredictable I've always felt
he was predictably unpredictable and
that's what we're gonna see
well you know he was offered a zoom
arraignment I mean and and refused it
this this spectacle is what he wants
right so yeah that I I am predicting he
will do or say something freaking
ridiculous he will walk out to that
crowd or something afterwards and you
know I'd say the court is playing right
into his freaking hands man I am so sick
of his two-tiered justice system where
this guy's not going to get printed he's
not going to get his his you know mug
shot like everybody else and book like
everybody else that's [__] I don't
give a damn who the guy is I don't care
what office he once held if you break
the law and you go through the justice
system it should be the same for every
damn person that walks through the
[__] door and uh you know
to me I'm seeing the media play right
into what he wants to play right into
what he wants
wall-to-wall coverage of trump yesterday
it was just like 2016 all over again
nobody asking a damn question just
wall-to-wall Trump men it was just
everywhere the Trump plane it was like
freaking banners all the free
advertising you wanted
to oh chase down the freeway
it kind of reminds me of that like the
2016 election oh okay well you know I
mean I guess that's fair enough uh
speaking of uh Trump's ears ears that
Don Jr's take on his little live he had
um see if you can figure out what a
stature a limitation is I don't know he
thinks he knows but let's let's see what
Don JR says office uh the fact that they
want to put a gag order a gag order on
my father so they want to charge him
with things that even the feds decided
not to charge and even though it's past
the stature of limitations and did you
catch that the stature the stature the
statue of limitations then I don't know
maybe I'm maybe I'm just off my rocker
but I don't think that's the word let's
continue even people like from The
Washington Post and like Fareed Zakaria
of CNN are like I don't know guys this
seems kind of crazy and then I read they
want to put a gag order on him so he
can't actually talk about the
persecution and The Witch Hunt that you
to go undergoing you can't make this
stuff up so okay so I've said this a
hundred times and I'll keep saying it
every single criminal indictment every
one of them if you were released of your
own recognance which means you're
released without an ankle bracelet
you're released without without a parole
uh officer coming to under super strict
supervision if you aren't in a jail cell
there are conditions of your release and
those conditions include always every
single time for a criminal defendant
because it's crimes if you if you say
certain things about your prosecution it
can be crimes especially if you're
witness tampering or you're trying to
pollute the jury pool intentionally
there's always a gag order always now to
what extent the gag order is and I want
to talk about this because this seems to
be one of the the things that everyone
keeps talking about the gag order this
judge is likely going to gag Donald
Trump now he will have the right to
remain silent Texas Paul I just don't
know that he'll have the [__] ability
but the gag order doesn't mean [__]
unless this judge is willing to enforce
it that's the way I see it are you
seeing it differently than I am a little
bit I don't I don't think they're going
to preemptively gag him because they are
trying to avoid any opportunity for him
to to ask for a uh an appeal which
you'll get anyways but they don't want
to give him the ammunition to do it
they'll wait till he does something
stupid they'll say okay you're you know
go have a nice day you've been uh
arraigned you're
here you go walk out the door and then
he'll say something stupid like he's
being persecuted
and he'll attack the prosecutor they'll
haul him back in and then they'll put a
gag order on him but they will make it
his own stupidity first they won't I
don't think they're going to
preemptively do it because it just gives
him ammunition like you see you know
little Fredo there just running his
[__] coked up mouth
um you know I'm surprised that dude can
even talk as numb as his face has to be
but
yeah I I really do believe that this
judge is pretty damn smart and he's not
going to gag him from the get-go he's
going to give him the rope and say here
you go go outside and hang yourself and
then I'll bring you back in and then
we'll gag you right well and that's and
that's a typical procedure too right
again he can't break any more laws
um based on him being arraigned and
indicted like he can't go too far to try
to tamper with Witnesses intimidate
Witnesses
um he can't he can't try to poison the
jury pool and which is all things that
he is likely to try to do right this is
Trump's MO is to obstruct that's just
what he does I won't be surprised if
there's actually obstruction charges
that Alvin Bragg has brought against him
today if there is obstruction charges in
in these however many felonies they have
I will not be surprised that there's
obstruction just won't be
um but but I think you're I think you're
on to something there when you say that
this Donald Trump this is not going to
be his last appearance in front of this
judge at the Manhattan courthouse and
the reason why is because this judge
this judge specifically is the judge all
the way up to the trial
um that's typically how it works in the
New York State system I was questioning
this the other day and it sounds like
that is what is going to happen now this
judge won't be the trial judge but he
will be with Donald Trump in this case
all the way up to trial which is
probably sometime in 2025.
um because I believe this judges it
seems like they're a fair he's a fair
judge it doesn't seem like there's
anything nefarious that this judge has
ever tried to do or or to be biased
towards one side or the other
um so it's likely that when Donald Trump
goes to the judge and their legal team
which he's hired actually a lawyer who
who is way better than Taco penis
um that is going to be representing him
in this case which I actually am I'm I'm
glad that he actually has a real
attorney because then he won't be able
to do this [__] all my attorneys were
[__] and try to use that is an appeal
he's got a real attorney now that
attorney even dropped his partnership at
the law firm where he's at apparently to
take this case now
when when this happens when heat starts
to try edge up to Breaking the Law I
believe that the judge will haul him in
back in court and we're this is not
going to be the last time but I do
believe that this judge will pump this
trial past 2025 because Donald Trump is
going to be on primary ballots folks
he's going to be on Republican primary
ballots he is going to be in an election
that is The Balancing Act that this
judge is going to have to do with a gag
order Mike Texas Paul says not only not
only is it about the law but it's about
it's about appeals and what he can and
cannot say and Donald Trump is going to
test every single one of those measures
I don't know if you met I don't know if
you've seen how the guy reacts to things
or how he again is predictably
unpredictable but he is going to test
every single bit of the New York and
Manhattan and the state of New York's
justice system here every [__] one of
them every single one of them
um I want to go to get your reaction to
some of the visitors that they have in
New York City today this first one um
he's kind of right up down to Trump's
alley he likes to lie he likes to commit
fraud and apparently he's showing up
he's showing up for president's
fraudster today in support here's here's
Jordan
George uh Santos
um well and I'm not sure if that's his
real name there's a lot of names that
people give him but watch as he scurries
away here from the media listen George
Soros is from New York uh I believe he's
from
um uh is he from Staten is that where
he's originally from Staten Island
anyways the point is this is that George
George knows New York right he knows how
it works there and he still has caught
off guard and I'm going to show you
someone else uh who went to New York
today who got way caught off guard who
got really scared and ran away but
here's here's here's George Santos's uh
scurry
support
no I'm not what do you feel that you
need to support the person
um I got Gabe Sanchez with us and my my
feeling is on this Gabe's end is that
you're gonna have an opinion but here's
here's how I take this is that George
Santos is there to show support for the
president and maybe when he gets
arraigned in in a New York Court
somewhere that maybe the president will
support him maybe that's what he's open
for I don't know maybe it's like a fair
trade kind of thing I don't I mean I
think I think he's certainly hoping for
that I think it's a bit of a reach in
terms of the expectation because look
when his arraignment day comes Donald
Trump might be
incapacitated right he might be
otherwise busy he might have something
else on his calendar for the next how
many ever days or years or whatever it
is but uh but the idea that George
Santos showed his face in New York City
where his constituents
have not seen him or heard from him in
months since taking office right
the fact that he was willing to show up
also in Manhattan to avoid his
constituents but show support for Donald
Trump when he doesn't have the decency
or the courage to actually show up to
his local district office so he's
showing up here one to grift two to stay
relevant right he hasn't been in the
news in a couple weeks so he needs
something and and three is the idea that
yeah he's like look if I do you a solid
maybe you'll do me a salad meanwhile
Donald Trump is like sorry Who Who Are
You he doesn't know who he is he has no
idea who George Santos is and George
Santos is hoping hoping he's like let me
just get five minutes of your time sir
in between the arraignment you know
Texas Paul what's your take on uh
um what's his name Anthony devolder is
that who uh is that what do you have to
say Anthony devolder Santos yeah that's
his name what that's his whole name
George Anthony the boulder Santos can't
forget Katara rabosh though that's true
that's true my take is exactly what Gabe
was saying I mean it's just freaking
infuriating this guy will not show up
and talk to his own constituents he will
not go to his own office in in his own
District right there in New York he will
not even he's dodging his own party he
won't even talk to members of his own
Republican party that want to talk to
him about freaking resigning because he
basically took them for a freaking ride
too they're pissed off they want to see
this guy he won't do that but he'll show
up to you know try to have a little
lunch with old Donnie douchebag but I
you know I just
this is what I'm talking about this is
what makes me so damn mad drama [__]
all day long do some actual work get
some things done nah ain't got no time
for that ain't got no time to meet with
my constituents in New York and worry
about their concerns but hey man there's
a camera over there and some attention
let me run over there and do that
[__] I'm tired of it these people
have real freaking jobs that's the
problem with Republicans is they think
this is all [__] drama I'm not
thinking I'm not just talking about
politicians I'm talking about their
voters their voters think that that's
their damn job is to engage in this
stupid [__] drama theater it's not
government
does things government had There's real
work to be done you know we're about to
have uh you know a serious problem we're
going to default on our damn debt
because the Republicans aren't even
trying to work through this they want us
to default on our debt they're hoping
they're absolutely they're desperate for
any kind of Crisis they can come up with
and they are and you've got freaking
George Santos who by All rights
shouldn't be in his seat who should be
working his ass off quadruple time to
earn his damn spot is out there playing
these damn Namby Bambi prancy idiot
freaking games man I'm I well I've got
another one for you I've got enough
speaking of members of Congress uh
there's someone that arrived in New York
City today to protest
um the mayor said um hey just keep it
and behave I think I got footage of her
here I think this might be her let's see
that's what it is just call him bro hey
Fred yeah just call me cute
oh whoops I thought that was Marjorie
Taylor green I really apologize I mean
they they sound pretty similar you know
pretty close right it's pretty close
right I mean what what am I supposed to
do I got it confused I really apologize
um for that let me let me go to an
interview that Marjorie Taylor grid
green did in a uh in a vehicle I think
this is her boyfriend isn't it yes that
that is what the rumors say many people
are saying you know if I had to if I had
to say you know many people are saying
that she's dating the the the newscaster
from rsbn okay so this is RSB and I
don't know what they did in the car
beforehand yeah you don't want to know
Tony you don't want to know here is
here's here's an instance of a clip of
Marjorie Taylor green because all the
other Marjorie Taylor Green's Clips are
going to play there's a lot of whistling
and you can't hear her because they are
louder than she is if you can imagine
the protesters there are louder than she
is I don't know how that's even possible
but it happened let's listen to this
little um interview on Trader TV News
Network with her little her little boy
toy here president Trump is joining some
of the most incredible people in history
being arrested today
she uh the Texas Bowl did she really
just say that did she just I no I I
think I know where she's going with this
but she literally just says some of the
greatest people to be arrested he's
joining me like what the [__] are you
kidding me this this is her take in the
back of an SUV what what do you think of
that
I you know if if she comes up with the
name Martin Luther King or Malcolm X or
anything like that so help me God oh
don't play Don't Play It Again
well let's let's see let's see what name
she's she's thinking of let's let's
listen
um Nelson Mandela was arrested served
time in prison Jesus Jesus was arrested
and murdered by the Roman government
many people throughout history that have
been arrested and persecuted by radical
corrupt governments and it's beginning
today in New York City
um and I just can't believe it's
happening but I'll always support him
he's done nothing wrong oh my God so you
heard it here the petty Yeti set off
Donald Trump is Jesus and like Nelson
Mandela he's Jesus Mandela basically
yeah I mean if you're gonna you're gonna
give him a nickname it's president Jesus
Mandela what the [__]
oh man
I I I she acts like she reads the Bible
but I don't think she's actually read
the Bible do you if she's saying well I
mean you would think that somebody who
did read the Bible and preaches the word
of Christ and how everyone should be a
Christian and should be so nice and
caring and not violent and not bigoted
and shouldn't have an affair with two
plus people and and and do things that
are you know
uh would go against the word of God
would go against the Ten Commandments
right
um you know allegedly the Unabomber
these are things you would not you know
expect from somebody who claims to be a
Christian but
Texas Paul what's your take on Jesus
Mandela president Jesus Mandela
it's worse than you thought my friend
yeah
I've got this beautiful little
hummingbird that's floating out my
window here and he's saying don't do it
Paul don't don't do it
Jesus Christ I mean really
freaking really you're going to compare
freaking Donnie douche rocket to Jesus
Christ and Nelson Mandela Nelson Mandela
who spent his entire life
fighting for the freedom of his people
and then when he got power turned around
and said we will not persecute our
persecutors we will I mean a man with
that kind of heart
she's comparing him to that vindictive
petty little piece of [__]
and and then Jesus
really
have you read a Bible lately I mean I
don't I don't think she's ever actually
read it I don't know if she can read
right I saw somebody somebody earlier
when I uh I had a tweet and I think it
might have been like and this is the
moment she knew that she had [__] up
right yeah I think that's the one I'm
about to play next yeah yeah and uh and
I think in that some somebody commented
what was she thinking going to NYC and I
was like whoa now thinking right what do
you think he doesn't think come on man
did you watch the 60 Minutes interview
she can't think well here's here's that
moment here where Marjorie Taylor agree
knew she [__] up let's watch
[Music]
go back to Georgia
oh my God so listen I I
I I've never actually been to New York I
would love to go to New York City
um I I would love to go there often
but I'll tell you that I don't have this
weird
fetish with calling it like Gotham City
or a hell hole because anytime I've ever
seen pictures or video like social media
videos of people walking around New York
City or dining at New York City or
showing New York City it's not Gotham
it's not a hell hole like this is all
but also like when people like you know
people call Chicago Gotham City and New
York Gotham because they they share that
same type of feel and architecture and
right and aesthetic but also Gotham City
is like she's trying to use it as a
negative it's fiction though right well
yeah it's complete fiction but she's
trying to use it as a negative and I I
would debate or I would argue that many
people including myself from Chicago
would be like no I got them City's
[__] dope dude I love Batman right
right like it's not you know it well
here in in the land of Gotham City Law
and Order does exist you do have a
vigilante but you also do have a police
force that's that's enforcing Law and
Order so it doesn't work the way that
she thinks it works right she's trying
to make it as like a Gotham cities oh
this is such a bad place right when
really it's the opposite of what she's
trying to say
well the other thing too is that the The
Narrative that they're trying to
construct here is that New York is a
hellhole that's why they're Prosecuting
Donald Trump right but
if you if you have any kind of sense of
I don't know just reality and do just
just a smidge just a smidge of your own
research and realize that New York City
is one of the safest cities in our
nation at one time it was not it is much
safer now than it has ever been before
now the the the idea the idea that post
coveted somehow the city is is falling
apart and and it's it's it's it's a
[__] listen they have the entirety
of the police force like forty thousand
officers on guard and ready to go today
and tomorrow and yesterday
this this idea that somehow they don't
have their [__] together and there and
the mayor was trying to make the point
yesterday hey you can come here you can
protest we will welcome you because New
York City is a city that will welcome
anybody but if you get out of hand
I don't know if I can protect you or not
like New York City listen you [__] with
the people there they will [__] with you
back that is just how it is going to
work and I have a few clips of that here
is here's her trying to make a statement
and it's really she's even got a
bullhorn and it's hard to even here on
this recording because
the noise against her is so loud but
she's complaining about noise and how
Eric Adams didn't want her to make
noises is that's not the only thing she
does is make noise let's listen
here
[Music]
the argument she's making now it would
go against this whole like police versus
BLM side exactly she's like oh well no
no no police are actually using the
force against the will of the people
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
you're saying her argument should be
consistent Texas Paul speak of the
consistency of Marjorie Taylor's Green's
Arguments for a minute would you
you know well first of all she's so
[__] stupid she doesn't know what a
hot mic is when you've got a microphone
and a bullhorn you don't put the
bullhorn against your face because
that's what the squealing was you hear
that wasn't people whistling back at her
she's too stupid to know that's her own
bullhorn screaming back at her because
she doesn't know to move the bullhorn
away from your damn face when you're
talking but anyways she doesn't know
what a damn hot mic is every podcaster
in the freaking country knows what a hot
mic is but not Marge anyways she is a
podcaster by the way I mean sort of just
I'm just sort of in it but but yeah I
mean I always bring up John Edwards you
know this same crime and you know they
talk about Alvin Bragg and she's always
talking about that [__] with Alvin
Bragg and this that and the other I
haven't brag I'll Tell You Folks has
prosecuted this exact case 40 times over
40 times he's an expert on Prosecuting
this case
has Alvin Bragg been in office I want to
make sure he hasn't been in office very
long but he's been a prosecutor for a
damn long time and I have to tell you it
feels like that that's a big number that
he's brought to Justice in such a short
amount of time
no he is not no he this was his job he
was a prosecutor before
maybe notice what he's doing he knows
what the [__] he's doing man
wait are you saying that the the
citizens of Manhattan voted for a guy to
be their district attorney their
prosecuted a prosecute crimes because he
knows what he's doing is that what
you're telling me because that sounds
the opposite of what the right wing is
saying they're saying that George Soros
hand-picked this guy gave him a bags of
cash I mean like stacks of real cash and
he was like yeah sure George I'll do
whatever you and the cabal wants and
I'll prosecute so what you're saying
though is is the opposite of what the
right wing is saying you're saying he
was yeah it's a blue area they hired the
person based on his experience and the
qualification that's weird they didn't
hire him just because because believe me
Alan Bragg he's a nice look he's a nice
guy but he's not a looker you know what
I'm saying I mean
he was not your prototypical candidate
you know but he's really good at his job
I would I would really not
want Alvin Bragg Prosecuting me I would
really not he is very methodical he's
good at his job man but you've got
Marjorie Taylor green out there that has
said so much ridiculous [__] and then
compare it to these exact same cases
John Edwards is the perfect example this
is almost an identical case to the John
Edwards case and every one of these sons
of [__] if you ask Marjorie Traders
green today should John Edwards have
been prosecuted they they didn't
prosecute him should he have been
prosecuted
yeah yeah absolutely I mean I'm
convicted pardon me I said prosecute I
meant convicted
um no
it's computer hypocrisy it's just
everything is through that political
lens man all of it Tony well all of them
too and I brought this up yesterday
because they keep saying that you can't
you can't prosecute someone who's a
politician you can't prosecute them why
they're in office or why they're running
like that's all [__] we watched the
Democratic senator from the state of New
Jersey go through prep Federal
prosecution of federal trial his name is
Bob Melendez and Bob Melendez not only
not only won his [__] trial and was
exonerated but he won I think I think
even the federal prosecutors stood down
after that when they were going to try
to prosecute him again but Bob Melinda
stayed in his senate seat ran a race and
be still kept his senate seat while
indicted while prosecuted while on trial
this nonsense that we don't do this in
this country is all a bunch of [__]
horseshit all of it we prosecute
politicians in this country all the
[__] time Republicans democrats for
election fraud for [__] that doesn't
have to do with their election [__] that
happens while they're in office that has
to do with their office bribes
corruption we we prosecute them on all
sorts of levels we actually yesterday
yesterday there was a chief of staff of
the governor of Maryland the former
Chief he's formerly alive now yeah
the former Chief of Staff of the
governor of Maryland took off he was
indicted he fled to Tennessee the FBI
found him yesterday he got to a gunfight
and had to kill the guy had to kill the
guy he's on a political staff of a
[__] Governor he was the chief of
staff of the governor get the [__] out
of here we don't prosecute we don't
prosecute people you people are [__]
boneheads and you've lost your way and
we should be loud about this just like
Jamal Bowman Jamal bones
wait wait wait he was a republican right
no no no yeah
now wait a second wait a second was he
prosecuted that had anything to do with
the presidential election I think that
it didn't have anything to do with the
presidential election right let me I had
everything to do with the government's
governor's race did it have to do with
the senate seat that Barack Obama
vacated to be the president United
States
absolutely and he's guilty as [__] yeah
yeah and wait wait did he get pardoned
by someone he did well he did actually
get pardoned he got his uh he got his
sentence commute oh okay okay but who
was that that was Donald Trump that was
Donald Trump
you know who's sycophants for Donald
Trump now in the media do you know who
it is
lightning rod blagoyage okay
coming from Chicago I know Rod
Blagojevich before before Rod was
governor we had another corrupt Governor
that was in office there is look
politics is corrupt but you had Rod
Blagojevich come in saying how he
was gonna clean it up I I wanna wait
wait before you go I want to clarify
something politics isn't corrupt people
are corrupt okay all right all right and
politics corrupts people easily
I'm going with him because Chicago
politics for a long time
you know for anyone for anyone who who's
heard the phrase the windy city I can
tell you it's not because of the wind
that's just a coincidence the windy city
is called why it's the windy city it's
because politicians are you know how
much they blow right in terms of the
lies that they'll dispel into the ether
when they're running or when they're you
know whatever anyway the point is Rod
belojevich corrupt son of a [__] try I
think it was like two million dollars or
something like that he tried to seal
he's tried to sell the Senate seats for
when Barack Obama was going to become
president that seat was up and so he was
in charge of replacing that seat and
then said okay well who's the highest
bidder and that dumbass was having
conversations in his office on his phone
that [__] was tapped they had recordings
he was done
and then he went to jail
and then he got out and you know what he
did immediately after
he has a podcast now that's called
lightning rod I think is the name of the
podcast so right he took he took a
little bit of time to relax and come
back you know and then he started a
podcast because of course it's all a
gift and you got to make money hey hey
easy on the podcast being a girl I'm not
saying all podcasts but I am saying that
certainly corrupt people you're right do
correct corrupt people will use it
speaking of podcasts being a Griff what
I want everyone to do right now is like
uh this this broadcast right now we're
almost to a thousand go ahead and like
this broadcast And subscribe to the Tony
Michaels podcast our grip here this is a
pro-democracy grip this is pro-democracy
propaganda folks let's look at look at
Texas fall he's getting really
uncomfortable
no I just had a horrible thought oh what
was that what was that uh Marjorie
Taylor Green's boyfriend you think he
likes them thicko toes man oh
he loves he loves he loves the little
wieners okay those little wieners right
at the you know oh
I don't see you keep saying I mean could
you imagine I mean come on everybody
here we're gonna have ladies and wives
yeah
before could you imagine knowing that
hunger brisket man Jesus we're trying to
get a thousand likes here you
[__] if you settle down people
are gonna be unliking this son of a
[__]
here's Jamal Bowman Jamal Bowman is the
one who had a scuffle with Thomas Massey
of the day over over gun reform
um here he is um in New York City yeah
and he's at the Marjory Taylor green
rally and apparently he's using his
voice like he did the other day uh in
the halls of the Capitol let's listen
oh I'm sorry let me let me back it up
the sound let's do it
you don't need to be in New York City
talking that nonsense go back to your
District you're not what are you doing
here you're here for politics you're
here cause you want to be VP you're here
for your own fundraising you're here for
your own nonsense Jamal Bowman knows how
to put it I don't know if you guys know
this he's a representative of uh what's
that place called New York oh yeah oh so
he's in his hometown there's a can you
go to the so the video where she gets
into the truck and drives off like a
little like a little
go to that clip because I'll show you
Jamal Bowman In that clip okay so um
it's the one that's vertical right yeah
um no no I think it's no it's horizontal
it's from rsbn is it the whistle one
no no no no no no
they get into the that one that one that
one that one that one that one okay okay
why are you looking for that I you know
he's echoing exactly what I'm saying
people are tired of this [__] the
Republicans have jumped the shark they
are tired of this [__] you know a
little little tiny D down in Florida you
know mess around what did I tell you Bob
Iger they Disney said oh okay we got a
fight on our hands they brought Bob Iger
back Bob Iger first thing he did was say
come see me and Tiny D went up there and
they had a little meeting and he said
shut your damn mouth two weeks two weeks
tiny D didn't say [__] and then he
started running in his mouth again what
did Disney do shoved his ass in a
freaking locker and said try me try me
they took it turned the dogs loose they
turn their lawyers
freaking DeSantis looks like a [__]
everybody's tired of this [__]
they're tired of it uh
I I don't know how to put it to people
this is what we need to be doing for the
next election you know Tony you know we
now is the time that we plant the seeds
for what we want to grow for the next
election and this
just painting these two pictures right
next to each other of Democrats working
doing their job running government and
the Republicans and the stupid drama
that is the [__] you we need to bring to
the next election
um so we hit a thousand so I appreciate
it I appreciate everyone hitting a
thousand out there if you can go ahead
and subscribe to the Tony Michaels
podcast if you haven't already and
download every single episode of the
Tony Michaels podcast on Apple Spotify
Google why we got the audience here we
might as well do some Shameless plugs I
mean we're on podcasters so we're kind
of grifters but this is the clip I think
you wanted to play I turned the volume
down because there's a loud whistle yeah
yeah so when we get to the when we get
to the end of the clip okay that is
where we get a crossover and Bowman
shows shows up again oh okay so but this
is her running away because she didn't
speak long her rallies
I watched her rally I watched her rally
and it consisted it was six
I think it was like 5 555 or it was six
minutes on the dock oh I think it was
five minutes and 55 seconds of what the
total from the point at which she was
introduced and took the bullhorn and
started speaking to the point at which
she stopped speaking and started walking
I think it was like less than six
minutes that's about three or four times
the the length that it took for Donald
Trump to have to pay Stormy Daniels 130
000 yeah the reason why we're here today
I think I'm just saying I'm just gonna
throw that out there okay so let's
listen again there's whistles in this so
I'm gonna try to turn it down so we
don't have the because I also like how
it says she was swarmed
I mean a lot of the people yeah worn by
whistles yeah right well these whistles
defeat fascism let's let's listen
if it'll play there it goes
and I got it down because of the
whistles they're they're really loud
[Music]
she jumps in the SUV
they don't let up yeah now the police
officers are trying to remove the crowd
so the SUV can move
[Music]
[Applause]
and here at the end is where you're
going to see Jamal Bowman is that what
you're saying yeah so on the right win
and I'll try to pause it yeah yeah we
can spot him here it's once that once
the truck drives off then he shows up
and basically
kicks him out how many whistles do you
think there are there's at least five or
six anti-fascists I'd say they were like
six billion
there he is there he is right there so
you see him here right here let's talk
about the truth he said let me turn this
up a bit so we can try to hear him over
the whistles
get out of here
[Applause]
[Music]
he's like I actually represent New York
I'd like to speak but also the people on
the side like get the [__] out of here
get the [__] out of my city it is New
York man yeah man you don't look there's
there's no F words are going to be alone
yeah there's an app there is there is
definitely one absolute truth to New
York City right it's you don't [__] with
New Yorkers New Yorkers hate Donald
Trump okay and the fact that marjor
Taylor green
has been talking a big game and I say
big game
since Friday when the arraignment or the
official indictment was announced right
and they're like all right the
arraignment's gonna happen sometime next
few days early next week she was like
I'll see you all there on Tuesday we're
gonna have a rally we're going to
protest
see you next Tuesday
well yeah
I think a lot of people are like all
right yeah we'll see you next Tuesday
then you've got Eric Adams who was like
look you come to my city and you [__]
around you're gonna find out so if
you're gonna come here you better be on
your best behavior because I know you're
a child and I have to speak down to you
because that's how you understand so
don't try to mess around don't try to
smear [__] all over the walls don't try
to [__] you know hit people you know
Riot whatever be on your best behavior
so she keeps saying like oh Eric Adams
and all this stuff you guys have a you
know Gotham City this place is a
[__] you got crime happening this
this that that all about what about ISM
right and then I want to point out I
want to uh sorry I wanna Donald Trump is
on the Move
um oh okay uh he has it looks like he
has arrived in lower Manhattan there
were rumors that he's gonna give us
because there's no cameras allowed
inside the person happens yeah the only
the only cameras that the judge is
allowing for is for official document
record right right um so there's gonna
be still cameras and they're designated
I think they're only going to be able to
take shots from certain areas right just
for documentation and for the historical
record because it is a press it sounds
like press will be able to take photos
uh right before the arraignment in the
courtroom but as soon as it begins
they're out they have to get out now I
also heard that he was going I don't
know if it's true but I heard rumors
that he was potentially going to be
giving a speech before he walks in the
building right so keep in mind because
there's no press inside the in the
courtroom he's gonna try to find a way
on how to you know drum up support and
probably probably get b-roll footage for
political ads that he's gonna run I
wouldn't be surprised if that was you
know some of the goal of today because
again I don't know if this is true but I
did hear
he could have done this via Zoom okay
and the fact that he did they gave him
they gave him the opportunity yeah yeah
yeah now again I haven't confirmed that
but that is what I heard uh that he
could have done this via Zoom
to do this whole thing however Donald
Trump has decided to capitalize and
grift off this and waste taxpayer money
by showing up to New York well I think
the other thing is what Texas fall said
earlier this is about this is about
attention on the media because you see
here this is c-span's feed and they have
commentary going on here I've got it
muted but but they they're following his
every single move this is like I'm
telling you he's gonna use this and make
ads out of it he's gonna be like look oh
he's got his son he's got he's got to
have his own film crew oh yeah
he's gonna sell when they issue the gag
order he's gonna say I mean Roger Stone
is already on other news networks
talking about how the gag order is a a
suppression of your first amendment and
how it's actually election interference
right so they're already coming up this
argument of how it's unfair
even though if you know we want to talk
about fairness it's that Donald Trump is
treated the same way ever any other
criminal is you know what I would love I
would love for him the challenge in
court this gag order and to see how
unconstitutional and against the First
Amendment really yeah go ahead [__] do
that
um here is a little bit um before
Marjorie Taylor green got to New York
City
um this is was the um welcome that she
was getting here I want to show you how
how New Yorkers respond to people like
Marjorie Taylor Greene and George Santos
coming down to Manhattan watch this
so there's no there's no uh she did she
did tell people to bring pots and pans
she said bring instruments bring pots
and pans we'll have whistles too
I'm really ran away from the whistles
yeah she tweeted about it man I have all
these tweets screenshotted for uh what
was that because everything [__] blew
up on her face you thought she was gonna
go to New York and have no problem she
was
she likes to act like a tough guy but
she's literally tweeting out the
whistles were hurting my ears they were
assault is that really what she was
tweeting
I am not kidding she was saying they're
assaulting me with whistles
she she did uh there's an article that
the the post-millennial wrote and it was
talking about how there were hundreds of
supporters for for Margaret Taylor green
and she even tweeted from her personal
account being like I was so proud I was
there and people were you know
supporting Donald Trump she was there
for less than six minutes and she
[__] ran away because whistles were
in her does anyone remember when she was
on her America First Nazi tour with Matt
Gates and she literally said at the
podium we will not back down
then there was some hero with a whistle
off camera blowing blowing blowing
and guess what she did guess what she
did she backed down she ran away so
she's tweeting this video and she's
saying left-wing activists are handing
out whistles to shut her up watch this
I've never seen this I'm just I'm just
showing this video that I found she
retweeted this and they're acting like
these whistles are against the law or
something watch this
[Music]
um so we hear that Marjorie Taylor green
is coming to the city
um right here so we brought some
whistles to hand out to people to drop
her out with some noise
which is their constitutional right to
do I don't know if anyone knows that but
it is your constitutional right to stand
there with a whistle and blow that
[__] because whistles apparently
defeat fascism I didn't know I don't
even know that uh Texas Ball but
whistles apparently are antifa weapons
of war it looks like I tell you man
Gabe's absolutely right this did come
he's a [__] hero I don't know who
whistle guy is he covers his face but
that dude is the one that started all of
this and I am here for it I love it man
I mean and since then we've had whistles
at other little you know rallies or
conferences that she's shown up to when
she's shown because the first time that
happened was when they were protesting
or protesting Louis Gomer Matt Gates
marger Taylor green they were talking
about the unfair conditions of the Jan
six prisoners right that's where it all
started and that was the day that went
down in history as whistles could shut
Marjorie Taylor green up and cause her
to run away man ran away too yeah Matt
gets dude they ran away they got in
their truck right I mean it's a
whistle's work hella good on fascism she
said I mean you know just just like the
guitar this whistle kills fascists right
it does well here's here's here's one of
the fascist headlines this is the
article this is the post-millennial
right the most Millennial is is just a
[__] fascist nazi Rag and here's the
headline Donald Trump is innocent that's
the quote
MTG joins hundreds of supporters and
they're stretching it folks there's no
way they're not stretching it and that's
their and she retweed this Donald Trump
is innocent Margaret tethering joins
hundreds of supporters outside the
Manhattan Court ahead of arraignment
listen I don't know if you guys know how
many boats it takes to win to be
president of the United States or even
like a primary like to be a candidate
but it takes a hell of a lot more than
100 people interested or whether you're
getting a rain or not I'm just wanna you
wanna see you want to see a funny video
I just sent it to you so the this is
rsbn so I was going through footage this
morning to pull for a what was that I'm
gonna do on marjor Taylor green just
running away and one of these clips is
from rsbn now if you play it notice the
focus is on the uh the anti-trump crew
okay
and notice how they
they don't want to show because what
they're saying in the in the Tweet was
um they said divided anti-trump
protesters versus patriotic Trump
protesters in Manhattan so they show the
anti-trump protesters and then like
begrudgingly pan over and they like keep
it at the front where the barricades are
because they don't want to show more and
then they pan over and then you realize
that the pro-trump group isn't actually
pretty big and there's a lot of press
inside that pool well let's watch
typically used to doing uh this was kind
of out in their playbook uh for this
type of demonstration locked here what
what we have let's see if we can turn
down here I'm going to show you a great
example of someone that is here to do
nothing but instigate this lady right
here
oh that's that's crackhead Barney
oh man I I suggested that she come on
the show she does some crazy videos
posting on Instagram cracking and I'm
sure I'm sure we're gonna catch the
other side of that angle oh yeah we're
gonna get that video on her Instagram
for sure
um that's that's a great video that's a
great video have we heard from maybe
possibly the person yeah I texted I
texted Walter Walter should be down
there yeah and we're hoping we're hoping
he'll have a chance to uh maybe come in
uh with his cell phone and give us a
report from Denver I'm not getting
anything did you expect though that the
the the anti-trump crown would be much
bigger than the pro Trump ground I mean
that's what I expected you expect that
in New York City I mean come on is it I
did I did Trump's Trump time is over I
mean yes he's gonna win the nominee in
the Republican party yeah but his time
is over I mean he is a loser with a
capital l i mean just a freaking loser
and and
the magic's gone they're still hardcore
folks that are still sending them their
money and and whatnot and the media is
still going to try to make money off of
trump that that's why they did this
wall-to-wall coverage [__] and and
but no he's done man he's done stick a
fork in that fat ass he is done you're
not talking about this fat ass on the
screen are you because this is one of
the terms this guy looks like Francis
Buxton from peewee's Big Adventure well
you know what I don't regret to the game
you know he's got his constitutional
right to this discreet the flag only
once he's got it on his shoes but I also
can't tell if this guy's real right well
here's the thing is that do you think
Donald Trump would ever ever in the
history of ever ever give this guy more
than
um a quick glance and a and a walk away
because he would be embarrassed that
this guy supports him I mean really
honestly I mean you know I don't know
who this guy is but oh wait sorry I uh
it looks like Donald Trump has
officially been arrested tested okay so
we're announcing now that he's been
officially arrested yeah do we have can
you
can use footage of him walking into the
courthouse yeah um because it won't it
won't take long it won't take long for
them to arrest him almost immediately
and then they'll process him and then
they'll take him down to the arraignment
now that's the one thing I couldn't
figure out
um from the order that the judge gave
because there's not going to be cameras
allowed inside the courtroom but if you
remember like the Steve Bannon perp walk
where they cuffed him and they blocked
him from processing down to the
courthouse or excuse me to the courtroom
that was kind of the perp walk so I
don't know if they're actually going to
do that because it doesn't seem to be
that there would be a connecting
corridor from the booking room to the to
the actual
um courtroom the the place where they
will actually arraign him so he will
have to walk so I don't know if they're
allowing press in the courthouse to take
pictures and videos of that so we made
three minutes ago uh three minutes ago
Trump arrived to be arrested and
arraigned
I got a footage here I got footage here
the trucks
um this is him arriving
um so let's meet this and we'll watch
um this is the SUVs arriving in front of
the courthouse and he's gonna get out
um so here is here's Donald Trump and
they're going to do it fast
um again I I expected this that he would
get out quickly they would move him to a
certain area it is the Secret Service
the Secret Service is
um their mission is to protect a former
president doesn't matter what former
president it is
um and and that's the way it should be
so hey because I wouldn't want any
president to be protected I don't give a
[__] who it is and and just like I would
want any president to be charged with
crimes if he committed them or her for
that matter any president so here he is
uh
no I would just like to point out that
these Trump sycophants that they've got
on his secret service detail are the
worst Secret Service agents I've ever
seen well why would he want his videos
around him though Paul why wouldn't they
want them but look at them look at them
all they all have their back to the
crowd
they all when the truck pulls up you see
where it is you see the Gaggle over here
these people look at them they all turn
around and stare at the vehicle
not not where he's going to walk you got
one guy up there you see him up there in
the very back that is that is out in the
crowd that's a secret service agent you
can point them out because he's dip hit
[__] wear sunglasses for something I
mean this [__] here no back there
yeah
but every one of these agents should be
facing the crowd what is he waving to is
there was there someone he was waiting
did Melania I thought she was
adios baby adios
uh what a [__] Ding-A-Ling and
everyone's gonna be like oh my God this
is a history like look the problem with
this is is yes it is history yes this is
the first time we've ever crossed this
Rubicon where a former president was
indicted on criminal charges and what
we're hearing is going to be felonies
and we're probably going to hear the
news soon can you keep your eye on on
that game if we're gonna get
um as soon as they Reign him and what
the felonies are and if they're going to
release this publicly because my guess
is that they're gonna give
um his defense team the actual
indictment moments before he's indicted
because right they don't really need the
indictment much at this point because
they're gonna say he's not guilty on all
charges that's what he's gonna say it
doesn't matter what the charges are and
you know what Tony if I could throw this
out there please they keep saying well
they're Prosecuting an innocent man
every man prosecuted is an innocent man
in our country every single man
prosecuted is an innocent man until he's
proven guilty you know so this whole
[__] of well we're Prosecuting an
innocent man that's all they ever
prosecuted is innocent man I mean give
me a freaking break people this is
America
right right right
um do you have any word yet Gabe if he's
no I'm still I'm still getting the same
the only uh the only footage I'm seeing
right now is the same one where he gets
out of the truck and walks down the
street okay so here here's footage of
him actually coming out of
um the Trump Tower our perp Tower as
it's now called I think they changed the
sign out front to perp tower Tower right
right uh you can see him here this is
ap's video
and so here he is and then again he does
the stupid uh the Josh Hawley Nazi fist
pump I guess I guess I guess there's a
couple people down there that appear to
be Trump supporters in front of perp
Tower right there's at least a couple
people right maybe that are in support
hey
hey the two people
or New York City New York City hates
this guy he knows I would take a bet
that they're actually more reporters
there than there are actually approaches
yeah oh absolutely absolutely
well there's no there is no way that
that we've we've seen even since from
the point at which Donald Trump said he
was going to be uh arrested two weeks
ago on Tuesday right we saw people show
up and there was a a handful at Best of
people that were can you go back to that
other video for a second Tony I want to
point something out yeah well this one
is a live feed I'm gonna keep this as a
live feed um so I'll go back what are
you talking about where he came out of
the truck yeah when he came out of the
uh okay perp Tower yeah
um this is this is I'm gonna retweet
that that's a line where he pumps his
fist uh Gabe can you I'm gonna hang on
I'll say Let me let me get this
um can you make sure to keep track maybe
of this um that's okay man I just want
to I just I don't know anybody who I
just making yourself and hold it up in
comparison to your head okay that's my
fist that's my fist that is a normal
fist okay that is my fist now let's look
at tiny hands
compared to the size of his head
look at this little thing look at that
it's not even two-thirds of his head man
look at that little thing it's not even
half his head I mean this is my fist
look at that it covers my whole face the
other tiny little thing the other thing
you have to remember too is that the
position in which he has the fist right
like the furthest back it could be is
apparently it's like right with his face
most likely it's like a half yeah
further which would be even bigger like
mine yeah my hand gets smaller as it
goes away from the camera yeah so so
most likely it's out here like this at
an angle because we know he leans it's
like this it's like this look at the
size of my fist compared to his okay you
can't see my head you cannot see my head
it was right
[Music]
well yeah absolutely she said little
little guy
poor little guy poor little guy okay
she's going to have so much fun on this
show let me go back to this is again
this is a live camera outside the
courthouse and you see that it's that
nothing has erupted here again
um and it's just you know a lot of
people kind of gathered it feels like
that they're waiting for the news uh to
break so they can cheer and dance in the
streets my guess is that is actually the
footage that we're gonna get out of New
York there's not going to be a lot of
disappointed people up in New York
they're going to be excited this
[__] is finally paying for his
crimes because there's no one like a lot
of people hate Donald Trump Gabe Sanchez
they [__] hate that guy but there's
no no more bigger demographic that hates
Donald Trump than people who live in New
York City I mean he has literally since
the 70s been [__] on New York City
and they've had to deal with them and
they've had no way to get rid of him and
now it looks like through all of these
investigations whether it's Tish James
or this uh this arrange you know this
arrest that's happening or the other
three really that are happening Jan 6
Mar-A-Lago Georgia I mean New Yorkers
are like holy [__] thank God I mean we
might have a chance to get this guy out
of our [__] City can't do business
can't be here in jail
it'd be amazing and I'm sure a ton of
people through Decades of having to deal
with his absolute nonsense and and
debauchery and just looks like they're
making uh they're making a line here
they got as focused on law enforcement
yeah it looks like these guys are lining
up so they must did you know do you know
why New York City has so much
scaffolding
and go ahead
so the reason that uh that New York has
scaffolding all over right uh like on
the sidewalks you can see on your
sidewalks has to do with maintenance
right so basically there's a I have a
friend who lives in an apartment and she
was like she talked to a landlord and
basically was like why is there always
scaffolding out here why is it he's like
there's a loophole in New York City
that allows you to have scaffolding to
prevent from having to do certain things
with their building for upkeep but have
having scaffolding excuses you in
certain certain types of oh so these
buildings are [__] and you just put
scaffolding out and they can continue to
be [__] right here's a good shot of the
scaffolding and then you can put it's
always if you go yeah they were
scaffolding everywhere but it's a
loophole that that uh donors use or
building owners use I thought you were
going to talk about the window falling
out of Trump Tower the other day
I didn't even know that default
and the scaffolding is just this walkway
above the above the the sidewalk that
allows quote construction to happen
right
um but again it's a lot of advertising
for construction companies and I'm sure
scaffolding companies make a shitload of
money for in in New York City for
probably later I mean who would make a
[__] a lot of money because it's renting
they're probably renting this gambling
like you rent a fence right there's a
lot of fence companies I mean you go you
know every you know obviously people who
live there can speak on this but like
every you know every couple years I go
back to New York and the same
scaffolding will be on the same building
I was going to visit for a friend or
what have you right it's just always
there right
um but yeah it's it's not it's not there
because we're like oh we're doing work
all the time or we're building we're
fixing this this building it's actually
not because of that at all you know
what's crazy to me
oh my God
this is supposed to be a historic moment
right America is supposed to give a [__]
and be really concerned that that
um
that Donald Trump's being indicted and
this is like going to change our
democracy on Twitter the in the United
States the number one trending thing on
Twitter right now is Barbie the movie
um that's that's what's that's what's
trending folks is Barbie the movie now
if and I've said this before and I say
it in those Twitter spaces all the time
these people these right Wingers just
don't get that Americans don't give a
[__] about politics they just don't it's
not it's not that they don't want to
know or they they don't want to make it
important it's just they got better [__]
to worry about and they don't want to
have to know every [__] thing a lot
of people don't even know who the vice
president is they don't know who the
secretary of defense is they don't have
the secretary of state is they don't
know the the agriculture Transportation
I mean on and on on and on you go most
of them don't you know their [__]
Governor or their lieutenant governor is
they have no idea who represents them in
the United States Congress let alone the
senate or their [__] local legislator
they don't know who city council is like
today is election day in Missouri and
we're voting on we're voting on a couple
local referendums
um one of them is a tax thing for the
school we're voting on Council Members
um it just it just it just floors me
that these Trump people are so
delusional that they totally
underestimate that the country doesn't
give a [__] about politics they
definitely don't care about Donald Trump
and yes if he committed crimes they
probably believe that he should [__]
pay for them just like everyone else
does right like these people aren't
[__] concerned with the in and outs
of of your little [__] game about
politics and democracy and this is going
to topple our Republic because we've
prosecuted a former president get the
[__] out of here No One Believes that
[__] No One Believes that only the the
[__] 12 deluded people in this
country believe it
and not only that you mentioned Missouri
I mean like Wisconsin you know has
Supreme Court election today too like
another huge thing that's that's that
probably not a lot of people know about
right and and I think for most people
they might assume that there are two
elections right there's the general
election and there's a midterm and I you
know I don't blame people for not
knowing that there's more than that that
are happening throughout the year
in between those moments because there's
a lot to keep up with there's a lot of
[__] [__] that goes on every day in
our lives and it's a you know it's a lot
to to stay up to date and uh
the fact that we have wall-to-wall
coverage of Donald Trump waiting right
always plane landed in New York oh he's
going to Trump Tower oh he's like dude
he's not going anywhere okay he's not
gonna fly away he's going his Trump
Tower he's gonna hold out there until he
has to the final minute he has to show
up for his arraignment
he's not going anywhere but what we
should be doing is we should be focusing
on other things like what's happening in
Florida or what's happening in [__]
Tennessee Texas Paul today there's
historic foreign policy Finland is now
in NATO Finland is now in NATO that is a
that is like huge [__] news that that
there is a country now bordering Russia
the whole reason why they said they went
to Ukraine Finland now is part of NATO
in a NATO State I I mean that that
that's trending number eight and number
11. because Americans don't know and
don't give a [__] whether you like it or
not that's just the reality now we got
to keep yelling and screaming and be
loud about these issues so they do know
so we can make them aware of these
issues
but but Texas Paul Finland is is
accepted into NATO today that seems
significant is it yeah it's huge it's
freaking huge man and you know what
Latvia Lithuania Lithuanian and Estonia
would like to have a word about the fact
that they've been NATO countries on
Russia's border for freaking ever and
nobody seems to know they exist man
right
I mean I mean it's a big freaking deal
that Finland because man the the
bloodiest some of the bloodiest fighting
in World War II was in was in Finland it
really was I mean if you ever get a
chance to look up SEMO heya that guy was
incredible he was the I mean they called
him white death he's really interesting
if you want something interesting look
up Simo heya I mean the the this is huge
you know and and Russians are paranoid
people man to have Finland joining NATO
that's going to raise the temperature in
Russia I mean 50 degrees I guarantee you
man I mean they're sitting there
bullshitting around talking about oh we
won because Saudi Arabia is going to
sell some oil uh using the Yuan and then
oh we won yeah well we we got [__]
Finland how do you like that
yeah
I mean that's that's that's big foreign
policy news
um and and the Biden administration
supports that because it only makes NATO
stronger to ham Finland uh in NATO and I
know Ukraine is pushing to be in NATO
which again the whole [__] reason why
Vladimir Putin
um
well I mean there's a lot of lies around
why he he attacked The Sovereign Nation
of Ukraine but him being the border on
uh NATO state is one of them
um you gotta uh what's this YouTube feed
is this this is a CBS inside they've got
a commentator right now but they're
they've we've got live uh footage inside
in the hallway okay so this is the
hallway here
um let me see if I can get this going
here I'm really proud of you guys I want
to tell you that because you know all
the covers that we've seen of
wall-to-wall [__] boring stare at
the plane stare at Conair you know I
mean all the [__] not one takeaway
to anybody saying hey you know what
folks it's election day get out and vote
right one network did that [__] but I'm
very proud of you guys for reminding
people and yes we're talking about I
wanted I wanted I wanted election day
today go check your elections go vote
um here is here's the the hallway again
it's CBS News again a commentator on so
I I'm not you know [__] her commentary
it's my commentary here on the Tony
Michaels podcast
um if you want to go watch CBS I guess
that's one thing but you're watching the
Tony Michaels podcast but this is the
feed from inside the hallway which I did
say I said maybe we get a shot inside
the hallway like we did with Steve
Bannon
um I believe this is is this the same
hallway is this this could be the same
hallway I don't know I have no idea if
this is the same old way I couldn't uh
if you want if you want footage without
I don't know how long it'll last but
here's here's a here's a shot without oh
nice hat
here's a shot from NBC okay uh that has
them inside the hallway and the same
shot which I think which I'm assuming
there's a gaggle
of of press and journalists and
reporters that are right there at the
line and they've got all their cameras
set up for the shot which is down the
hallway they Flash the they Flash the
camera's light into the uh the bailiff
size like thanks a lot [__] yeah one
of the folks one of the folks in chat in
chat over here said I needed a [__]
man just happened to have a couple
available to me that's right that's
right if you want your own [__] pants
just go to the Tony michaels.com that's
the Tony michaels.com and you can get
your [__] hats uh there at the 20
minutes because this [__] ain't free
that's right well and well we do this
for a living and it that it takes money
to do it so subscribe to the YouTube
channel here if you haven't already make
sure to like the uh broadcast here uh
get us get us above 1100 I don't know
where we're at now
um but we're we're sitting down there
download every single episode of the
Tony Michaels podcast it's a great way
to uh support us and share every episode
and also if you want to give us money
for free if you want to give us money
for free and it didn't cost you a thing
if you're an Amazon Prime subscriber if
you get an Amazon Prime account just
link it to a Twitch account just link it
to a Twitch account you get one free
subscription with your Amazon Prime you
give us that one free subscription on
Twitch and we get a couple couple
dollars we're still watching the uh the
footage here of the hallway
um it looks like they are awaiting uh
the the former guy the the president
fraud president fraud
um to um
I love your audience I love your
audience best audience I might have to
use that and for a video that's pretty
good perv Walk we're gonna watch it live
here as it happens because I'm keeping
an eye on it because it looks like it's
okay I'm you know I'm I'm generally
curious uh
the you know how long the Raymond is
right because we we've heard right or at
least confirmed through leaks or other
people that it's 34 counts it could be
more than that we don't know but 34
seems to be the number that we've landed
on
um and then obviously you know the
timeline of events of like all right you
know Donald J Trump you are being
indicted uh or or convicted of these
charges right
and they go through and I'm sure I don't
know the the length at which they
explain each one
so I'm kind of curious how long they
have to be inside the actual courtroom
because obviously part of that's going
to be like all right look
there's going to be a condition to what
you can say what you can say follow this
or else here is the fine or the the
repercussions of that
um
but I can't I can't imagine I don't know
again I don't know but
I don't know what it looks like when
you're listening off 34 counts like how
much detail they're going into it you're
right the instructions are going to be
really interesting the instructions are
really going to be really interesting
because I do I do believe they're just
going to hand him some rope and say walk
out on the sidewalk and hang yourself
because I mean
I mean I if I was a judge I'd be like
look I'm giving you one warning
and and if you don't if you don't follow
and listen to what I say then this is
going to be the this is going to be the
actual repercussion and those
instructions those instructions in court
are going to last longer than the
arraignment itself so
um what what will happen what will
happen here in in my experience is
they'll bring Donald Trump into the
courtroom here soon after he's been
processed
um or whatever they're doing it feels
like the only thing they were going to
do is fingerprints and I that was the
only thing I think was confirmation that
they might do they they weren't what was
it so was it
I can't imagine they wouldn't do a mug
shot though right well they're saying
yeah but they're saying but they're
saying they wouldn't they're saying that
they wouldn't do a DNA it looks like it
looks like they're preparing ah no maybe
not
and they're letting some wait but how
can you how can you do that without a
mug shot right I feel like you have to
well because their claim their claim the
the Court's claim and the
um the bailiff and the people processing
claim is going to be you're not gonna
not know who he is right like and the
other thing but that was a lot of people
get to submit a [__] headshot like I
mean I mean he is Donald Trump so I'm
sure he's got a few but here's the thing
I I I I I I am I am of the belief that
he should have to do this right yeah
because everyone else has to [__] do
it he should do it like Martha's there's
a [__] mug shot of Martha Stewart is
it Martha Stewart wasn't a really
[__] famous person at the time when
she was arraigned and she had to do a
mug shot and she had to give her DNA in
her fingerprints like everyone knew who
the [__] who doesn't know Martha Stewart
is so I mean this idea that he's too
famous to do this [__] get the [__] out
of here just do it now the the idea of
it being released that's the thing you
know I don't know we wouldn't know what
the ramifications of his mug shot being
released would be until after it would
happen but apparently his team was
trying to secure that they would be able
to use his mug shot on merchandise
and they would have like exclusive
rights to it or some [__] like look this
is a mug shot man what the [__] are you
doing the reason we'll see it is it's
all public property yeah right right
right
well they would have exclusive rights to
it at all but speaking of merch man you
had one of your one of your folks in
chat I wish you'd pop up or she or she
would pop up again had a great idea for
you guys to get ahead of the get ahead
of the Curve [__] em whistles
[__] them whistles [__] em whistles I
mean that was a great not my idea
there's one somebody in chat pop-up say
who who said it but I saw it flash by I
didn't catch your name man I'll work to
see a [__] them whistle this man [__]
them whistles and we'll get bags of
[__] whistles and send them wherever
Marjorie Taylor green is going antifa's
coming or or Taylor green now calls him
his trans Tifa because of course oh my
God that's how much is actually better
that's even better that's even bad [__]
I like it let's do it trans Diva let's
capture their [__] name and run with
it these people are so goddamn stupid
they're just they're just [__] dumb
it it just it um oh we reached 1200 1200
likes people are saying 1200 likes on
the uh on the video here so thank you
very much for joining us today it's one
of the biggest audience live audiences I
think um we've had in a long time so I
appreciate you guys joining us here you
should join us every single weekday not
just today but every single weekday on
the YouTube channel so hit subscribe hit
the Bell notification so you get
notified when the broadcast is live you
can watch it live on YouTube Twitter and
twitch noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific
on YouTube Twitter twitch and Facebook
every single weekday for two full hours
today we're gonna go over because we're
already at the two hour mark but we are
going to go over we're probably gonna
take a few breaks here once we watch
this guy do a burp walk into the
courtroom
um Paul if you need a break just let me
know
and then gave the same way we'll try to
get in and out here with the uh with the
three hours going
um but also here's I'm gonna have to run
on you guys uh here in a minute just for
a second I gotta I I like I said I got
covered the wife can't bring me coffee
I've gotta hold my breath run out to the
coffee pot
do you have to hold your breath when you
take a piss too is that I don't know how
covet works I haven't had it yet so yeah
run in shut the bathroom door and then
when I walk through the house you
haven't had covered yet no I haven't no
I no I I have it now no no you yeah you
have it
no I didn't get covet until
two days before Christmas let me let me
say this I don't know if I've had
covered because I've never done the the
test where it says if you have or not
well you know like Donald Trump says if
you don't test then you don't have coven
well I guess not but I mean I've never
had I never had the the symptoms and
when I did have symptoms or something I
it was always negative so I I don't know
it's funny you're saying that because I
I I'm vaccinated I get vaccinated
regularly I'm gonna think I'm on my
fifth vaccination and
um I had no idea I had covered and I
wasn't I wouldn't get a test I thought I
had a little seasonal allergy thing
going on that was it you know I mowed I
mowed my yard day before yesterday I was
feeling fine I'm still feeling fine I
mean look how good I look man
that's that's some good looking coven
right there I wasn't gonna test you know
I never even crossed my mind and then my
wife follows Cruz Facebook and then
apparently a whole bunch of these Trump
bumpers on the boat that don't get
vaccinated are getting laid out
and they all have to go one of them gave
it to you but to give you the vaccines
work man my wife does not have covet I'm
telling you I barely feel it vaccines
work people right well that's crazy it's
crazy what science can do and when you
accept science into your life it can do
wonders
the religion of science I love it I love
it and when you accept science into your
life you know I I bet I bet science was
another really famous person that was
arrested too that joins that Trump joins
is Jesus Jesus Mandela in science that's
probably or again we're still awaiting
here uh the the perv walk as someone
called it in the chat
um from Donald Trump uh there Texas Paul
if you need to take a break go ahead and
and hold your breath and grab your
coffee
um me and Gabe will hold down the fort
here and Gabe if you need a break just
let me know yeah I'm gonna need a break
here in a minute because I've had a lot
of coffee but I want to wait I'm gonna
hold it until um
until we get the per block because
apparently the the um the the
the the the
you know the thing the thingy thing the
arraignment is supposed to happen at 2
15. that's when it's scheduled so that
is
28 minutes from now no 18 minutes 18
minutes can you control can you can you
can control the uh that that footage
coming up can't you even though it's on
my the the one right now down below I
can control it yeah try it try it bring
it up bring it up come on
okay yeah yeah I'm just making sure you
can use it I could I could so you know
yeah so I'll keep that going I'll keep
that going just in case I gotta you know
Nature Calls
um yeah no I get it you know when Nature
Calls you gotta get going you know okay
Texas depends on how much coffee you had
this morning right
I can hold my breath
I am telling you
who did you get your coffee did you get
your car I did you got it foreign
[Music]
okay well I'm gonna bring this up I'm
gonna go take a break I'm gonna let well
wait maybe maybe don't don't don't speak
so soon here God damn it I got it
because
the arraignment is scheduled for 2 15
Eastern right and right now it's two two
Eastern let's call it look it looks like
they're playing in here so like I
imagine the walk between then we're
gonna see this guy here this guy here is
like we're gonna go down there and then
it's gonna go over there and then and
then he's gonna come out that fat slob
is going to come out and we're gonna
Circle him here we're gonna do a little
do you think is he behind those doors
totally misinterpreting that that guy is
saying look the donut shop over here is
not really that good the one over there
though two blocks that way on Mott
Street yeah that that is some excellent
donuts over there they put the Italian
cream inside them that that's the good
Donuts
choreographing uh the the perv walk as
we're calling it in the chat
um they're they're
um
oh my God he's pointing out where all
the good donut shots are okay we got
some movement here I don't know who
these folks oh is this is this the
courtroom this might be the courtroom
door that we're watching here not the
[__] not the [__] processing oh is
it I don't know because everyone's
looking down the hallway as if um he's
gonna come from that direction if that
makes sense well because the barricades
are up and that they're they're parallel
to where the Press is right now I don't
know if the barricades go the full
length of the wall so so I don't know if
he's going to be coming from the left
and then goes through the doors or if
he's coming out of those here's what I'm
gonna do I'm gonna go real quick and
then I'm gonna let you handle the
coverage
so yeah let me uh here I'll pull I'll
pull this bad boy up that way you don't
miss anything
um so yeah who knows I don't I have no
idea to lay out look I've never been a
reigned you know thankfully I don't know
the layout of this uh this Courthouse I
don't know exactly where he is
um but I am looking forward to the
whatever this short walk is in and out
um
because I don't know I'm curious how
long it'll actually be the the actual
uh arraignment process right because
like I said I don't think the accounts
should take very long to go through
right it takes it takes a few minutes
because they've got to read they've got
to read his indictments I mean it it
you know I I don't think they're going
to stipulate it I think they're going to
do their p's and q's to the end and
right it'll take a few minutes to go
through it and again I think we'll give
them they'll give them the you know the
full documents to be like here is
everything you know here's the syllabus
and I think the instructions are going
to take a while because I I think they
are gonna because because of the stupid
tweet he made holding the baseball bat
and threatening Alvin brang
um I think there's going to be some
pretty serious instructions about what
he can because you know I mean hey he's
a citizen of the United States of
America he can protest his innocence all
damn day long they're going to need to
draw for him where or at least have his
attorney affirm that he's drawn for him
where the lines are you can you can't
you can't accuse the prosecution of
being corrupt you can't accuse the
prosecution of you know
you know victimizing you but you can
protest your innocence all day long
right and if you look at like you know
if you if you track back through what he
was saying today you know heading to
lower Manhattan the courthouse seems so
surreal wow they are going to arrest me
can't believe this is happening in
America
and it's like yeah we can believe it's
happening because you committed crimes
and you know you committed crimes and
now there's the consequence portion of
you taking your action right wait are we
at are we at the find out stage the [__]
around soccer I think we're beginning to
cross that Chasm right there's like this
moment where he's entering the fight
like when he gets the full list of
charges right or the the the the counts
in which they're they're charging with
that I think is he's opening the door to
oh we're in the we're in the find out
stage here
because I don't think that's the
obviously the full find out stage for
this phase
there's going to be the find out stage
of the Manhattan DA's investigation and
how he follows through with uh with
talking about it right like how he
reacts to it publicly how he talks about
the case how he attacks you know Alvin
Bragg's wife or John or Jack Smith's
wife or whoever might be
it's going to be something that's going
to it's just get you know Pandora's Box
essentially of the find out stage and
that's just for this phase right and
just like when when Alvin Bragg gave
the um the press conference after the
Trump or was found guilty of 17 count 17
counts of fraud he said we're closing
the chapter like we're we're ending this
phase right here right the next phase is
the one that we're experiencing right
now and I'm sure there will be a
follow-up phase uh for additional
charges whether they're obstruction or
their
um they're violating the gag order
whatever it might be like there's more
you know it's not just a one or two
chapter book that Elven Bragg is is is
uh is showing us right there's multiple
chapters to it
um I gotta ask you guys I mean talking
about I mean this just proves what a
sociopathy is because I want you two to
think about it how would would you be
surprised if your lawyer went down
for this exact crime
I mean would you really be surprised
really really surprised that the guy
that you paid to pay off this porn star
got arrested and went to jail I mean he
went through his whole try are you
really surprised or are you just such a
sociopath that you had no emotional
attachment at all to anything that
happened to Michael Cohen right the idea
that he can that he can literally be the
person who committed the crime who had
the conversation about the crime with
your lawyer Michael Cohen who got in
trouble right who who went to jail you
know he who served his time
um and the fact that this is coming back
up something that you thought was
totally dealt with you thought you had
the protections of the presidency you
thought Bill Barr would protect you in
these certain things right you you have
yourself now stuck in a moment where
you're you have to ask yourself you know
because again I think he really does
know
the reality because I'm sure his
handlers and his lawyers are like look
this is the likelihood of what's gonna
happen and here's the likelihood of
follow-up things that will happen
because of this investigation and I
think for the most part he understands
but I think it's his ability or
inability to accept right so he knows he
he's aware of the potential problems but
he's unwilling to accept the
consequences for his actions for the
things that we have shown to be true and
shown to have uh you know punishment for
I just want to remind the audience that
we're about 10 minutes away from the
scheduled arraignment he's supposed to
be uh arraigned at 2 15 Eastern it is
now uh 206 Eastern uh and so we're less
than 10 minutes away now from the
scheduling of Donald Trump now we know
Donald Trump's always [__] late so I
don't expect him to be in the courtroom
exactly at 2 15. but here's the thing
here's the thing that gets me the best
is that he usually wants control over
everything right like he wants control
of the theater and the choreographing he
has real not a lot of control here right
yeah like he doesn't have control and
that's probably what is pissing him off
the most and that's probably where all
the the the positioning was the last few
days about was he going to do it Zoom
what is he going to go to New York what
is he going to write Fanfare this and he
decided to go ahead and make a show of
it even if he doesn't have ultimate
control
and to also show how disingenuing all of
this oh they're surprisingly the person
you know scy Vance came out and said
last week Bill Barr threatened me and
made me drop this case right I mean I I
don't think that people can appreciate
that are outside the the bubble can
appreciate just how much like the
Manhattan district attorney which deals
with that office is huge folks it's not
just Manhattan I mean there's a reason
that the court cases from the Virgin
Islands are coming up to the Manhattan
District Attorney's office as part of
their purview it's a huge office and
when the doj says you dropped this case
or else you're looking at losing all
your doj cooperation you're looking at
your entire I mean your entire office
being crippled yeah because Bill Barr
wants you to drop this case
he cannot be surprised he cannot be
surprised he had his dog go out there
and crush this once you know I mean this
is not he knows the Jeopardy he's in
right and and Trump himself right like
the idea that or rather his supporters
the idea that right now you hear them
being like oh this is a political
persecution this is totally unfair and
this is unprecedented and this and this
and that and it's like look
you guys are you guys know
the end is coming you see the end of
your orange troglodyte right you see the
guy
and the likelihood
that one of these investigations it's
funny enough that you know the [__]
grabbed back in this moment but you look
at the other investigations that are
coming towards him and the Trump
supporters I think in some part of their
mind
accept or see that the end is coming and
they're on well sorry they see the end
is coming and just like Trump they're
unwilling to accept the reality of that
event right and so they're gonna say oh
it's unfair
this is uh this is all political it's
it's a two-tier justice system this and
that and it's like no the you're finding
out more than what we originally knew
you thought it was one or two counts
because of a porn star turns out there's
34. turns out that there was another
woman that he paid hush money to to be
quiet turns out that you know side Vance
comes out and says Bill Barr shut this
[__] down you're finding a lot of things
that are more than just oh it's Stormy
Daniels and it was a hush money payment
you're finding out that there's you know
again there's more to this than anyone
knows and the people who are commenting
just like us right it's all it's all
speculation we don't know
we won't know unless we until we see the
actual uh list
of charges or the counts that he has
against him after he's arraigned from
the judge right like we won't know those
things and just for that same group
that's uh you know the trumpers they're
they're hoping they're like oh no it
can't be the thing that we fear because
that's the thing they are fearful
of this actually taking him down
or at least being one of the things I
take him down
and they're unwilling to accept it right
because that would be the end of their
reality that would be the end of their
whole personality
yeah and and you're right because
people seem to have forgotten the name
Karen McDougall exactly she's the other
woman involved in this that they they
paid hush money to this was something
that Alvin Bragg looked at also so yeah
I will not be you're absolutely right
there guys I would not be surprised if
this is not just from stormy Daniel and
some things that we didn't even think
about I mean they've been looking at a
lot
you know and and the idea that a bunch
of people on the right say oh here's
here's Alvin Bragg Alvin Bragg just
walked out um Alvin Brad walking into
world wars to be the courtroom all right
so we got five minutes till the
arraignment right so Alvin brag and the
prosecutors are going to go set up
they're going to wait for the defendant
to come
um again I want to remind everybody just
like Texas Paul said earlier as much as
we know in public and have a lot of
evidence in public and mainly his
projection of his guilt or his innocence
whichever side you're on you hate
Watchers out there this is Donald Trump
is Presumed Innocent just like any other
Defender yeah
um he is pursued Presumed Innocent he's
going to be arraigned on several felony
counts the word is it's going to be 34
felony counts but we'll wait to see Gabe
do you have any word if they've dropped
the
um since Alvin Bragg has walked into the
courtroom if they have dropped the
actual indictment for the public to see
because they will unseal it at some
point
at some point they will unseal it for
the public to see also they have to give
it to Donald Trump's attorneys and they
will and the judge will have to present
the the indictment to Donald Trump and
then arraign him on that and then
they'll yeah I don't think it's guilty I
don't think anything is going to be
released until it actually enters the
courtroom like he's got to be the first
one to see the actual charges that's
that's not Norm I mean it doesn't have
to be that way but I think it is
yeah or what could happen is as soon as
that goes down because they can't have
press inside what could possibly happen
is they release
at the same time and say we are now
letting as soon as the right thing
there's a different perspective it looks
like this is the um uh of this is a
perspective that is further back right
um from what we see down there at the
doors of the of the of the courtroom
where Donald Trump will be arraigned so
this is looking down the hallway where
he'll be rained this is a closer shot of
that of those police officers and uh
Court officials waiting uh for Donald
Trump uh to enter the the courtroom
where he will be arraigned by a judge
now this is the same judge that was the
judge in the trial for the Trump
organization and Alan weisselberg that
was his whole theory of why it's all
rigged and all this [__] and why
it's the systems against him but these
judges are picked at random and and they
have confirmed that this judge was
picked at random so it just so happens
that he got the same straw that he drew
for the trial of trump organization and
that's just how it [__] works when
you commit crimes in these same
jurisdictions it's going to be the same
pool of Judges like if you keep criming
in an area and you keep doing crime in a
jurisdiction where these judges preside
it is likely that you might get the same
[__] judge if you keep criming so
here's my suggestion Grandpa stop
criming that'll help like that'll
[__] help this whole situation if you
want to do that like the Jim Carrey clip
stop breaking the laws all right right
that comes to mind that comes to mind
too but I mean you know I wanted to
expand on what Gabe was saying there
though you know this is a very public
case you know when the Jack Smith stuff
comes out because there will be
classified documents they'll be sealed
indictments that we're not going to be
privy to they're not going to release
that information but I don't think I
don't foresee anything coming out of
this being sealed this is all going to
be a matter of public records right I
believe I mean these things now they're
discovering the discovery we won't see
till trial we won't see a lot of the
discovery till trial but the list there
shouldn't be anything that's redacted
for that I mean they're just you know
they're they're uh they may they may
redact they may redact or rename
Witnesses oh well yeah yeah sorry for
the witnesses but the actual charges
itself right like the the 34 charges
they're looking at or that we know of
you know these are all these are all
related to the business so I can't see
anything like you know Texas Paul is
bringing up you know you're going to
have sealed documents you're gonna have
redacted information in terms of what
the charge was you know and for this one
it's a you know it was a business
issue right that that that is what the
charges are years or
whatever how many whatever it is in
relation to the Trump org that he paid
off Stormy Daniels with
so there shouldn't be anything there
that's like oh this is sensitive or this
is classified or top secret right
especially if he did it as a private
citizen I just want to point out I just
got a notification from True social
because I have the app downloaded on my
phone so that I can keep track of
Grandpa Poopypants I just got a
notification from this right now Trump
arraignment at New York City Courthouse
watch here so they're airing
trumps of course they are on his social
media did he post it or did some where
did he do that I don't know it just it's
just it's just a notification from True
social oh I think they are badly
misjudging this I think the Trump Camp
they really think this is going to be
good for them and the Republicans
started that whole air in the public
media oh this is just going to be great
for Trump it's going to secure his
nomination and he's going to be more
powerful than ever I think they've
they've started buying their own
[__] and are really misunderstanding
just how tainted and broken he's going
to to be when he walks out of this
courthouse today he will be indicted for
crimes that are open and shut literally
these cases aren't tried there's no
there's no oh we got to rely on a
witness testimony they open the book and
say see this line
okay well that's the check then they
open this book see this line it's not
here because this is the
Texas fall I actually think that we
could see obstruction charges this is
Donald Trump we're not out of the woods
of obstruction charges we could also see
a conspiracy because when you start to
rope in
um different hush money payments to
different people and if they were using
the same scheme and they were and and
they were conspiring in the same way
that goes to conspiracy because it
wasn't just a one-off right there was a
conspiracy to to conduct this business
so if there's a pattern
I think we could see more charges that
are related to the business fraud but um
maybe it's maybe it's conspiracy maybe
it's maybe it's uh obstruction we know
Donald Trump loves to obstruct so I
actually I actually believe that the 34
charges could be a ray of different
things and until we actually get them
unsealed and we see these things we
won't know if the what the witness
testimony directed The the D.A to do or
not to do what charges to bring or not
to bring we won't know if there's
evidence which the the idea that there's
evidence of this business fraud is very
ample and the reason why is because
cybance wanted to go after this in his
district attorney's office when he was
the district attorney before Alvin Bragg
and Bill Barr told the sdny to tell him
to stand down now my take on it is is
that cybance which is a normal thing
when feds tell a local prosecutor stand
down we're going to investigate this
that local prosecutor thinks okay the
feds are going to take the case well
they didn't take the case I mean they
took it and buried it underneath the rug
somewhere so that way you wouldn't be
prosecuted in in the sdny right and then
all the while he won't be prosecuted
into Manhattan DA's office and I believe
yes I was just gonna say it it turns out
that uh Donald Trump is already selling
merch is he really he's selling he's
selling a fake mug shot on a t-shirt are
you [__] kidding me oh my god do you
have this is uh no no joke this is from
Aaron rupar
uh and he's reporting that he just got
an email or somebody got an email and he
now has a screenshot of it and it says
not guilty president Donald J Trump
45-47-0404 2023 I'm gonna go to this and
then I'm gonna go back to the live feed
real quick there's the fake mug shot I
think I've seen this one on Google
Images this morning so they probably
ripped 50 bucks for a t-shirt is insane
that is that that's that feels like the
same amount of money that Kanye West was
charging for a white T-shirt
well like it's it's insane if there's
been a grift you know what I mean the
fact that he's already I mean like dude
we I mean we talked we said it yesterday
on the show we're like he's gonna he's
gonna sell a fake mug shot and then
maybe they end up releasing the real mug
shot you know I don't know I don't I
don't know if they took one or won't
take one or I mean I guess we're gonna
find all that stuff out right with time
yeah
but it but again his supporters are
gonna [__] buy this [__] they're
gonna think he's a martyr and it's only
gonna be a small percentage of this
country who believes this garbage it
really is it's not gonna be a large
percentage of people who are like oh he
needs to be Vindicated and he's innocent
get the [__] out of here everyone knows
this guy is a liar he's a cheat he's a
fraud he's a crook we all know this
frankly a lot of these [__]
Christians out there voted on voted for
him twice knowing this and being okay
with it because really honestly in the
American Christian religion frauds kind
of fit in don't they I mean you know I
mean they go hand in hand right
scriptures with sexual assault crimes
too well that that is true
um especially when you have manga like
Marjorie Taylor green calling all
Democrats pedophiles on my 60 Minutes
interview and the best Leslie Stahl has
is wow wow wow wow what she did was like
crazy wow wow wow she did an exhale and
then said wow and then said okay and
then moved on right no pushback no
pushback
I love how the ratings tanked just to do
a trump honor you know sad you know
nobody was watching total loser Marjorie
Taylor green just couldn't draw an
audience nobody wants to see Spork foot
everybody wants to see Donald
knowing
sad so do you think do you think we're
bringing that up do you think he
directed her to go to New York City or
you think she's trying to steal his
Thunder no I think she coordinated with
him because if you look back on her
Twitter feed there are official
photos
from the Trump campaign that are like
with his logo on it with some like go to
her go to her uh her her Twitter page go
to do I have to yes I'll tell you why go
to the rep MTG one
uh oh so her official Congressional
official one she's been doing on both
but if you go to rep MTG you'll see that
she's been posting about how she was
gonna be there at 10 30 a.m eastern time
in Manhattan to to rally and protest
against the political persecution of
Donald J Trump and how it's unfair and
we need to voice our concerns and we
need to show up we need to be Mega
strong she tweets a lot of garbage but
there are seven photos that she shared
she's his vice president I'm gonna I'm
just gonna say it right now she's his
vice president oh you think so you don't
think Gary Lake I think I think she's
she's and this this was her this was she
was supposed to come out here with the
credit Carrie Lake might be it now
because of how badly Spork foot failed
on this but that is that coordination
you've been I've been watching that two
game you're spot on it you know campaign
material coming through Marjorie Trader
green site and then that's why they put
her on on 60 Minutes with Leslie Stahl
was they were gonna see if she could go
through for a prime time and and and
help out the campaign
she bombed on 60 Minutes she's failed
today this may be her way out the door I
mean you know I mean her her her her
being shown the door after this we'll
see next week but yeah I absolutely
believe that she was she was going to be
his vice presidential candidate and this
was supposed to be her moment to shine
they're replaying the moment replaying
the moment where Alvin Bragg walked in I
don't mean to cut in here but we're
we're um we're about 10 minutes past the
time which I I said he would probably be
late which I guess
I'm right as always I'm just saying just
point that out there okay sorry it was
sorry it was not from her uh apologies
apologies it was not from her actual uh
her official account from as a
congresswoman it's from her personal
account but on here if you pull that up
you'll see a second oh my God come on
man
Hatch Act that's why it's not on her
Congressional account
right um yeah exactly well well it you
think she wouldn't be above um yeah I I
mean she does some stupid [__] also is
she going to Mar-A-Lago tonight
how I how the hell am I supposed to know
this do I I feel like she is
join me tomorrow at 10 30 at nyrc to
protest the political persecution Donald
J Trump in New York City at the collect
Pond Park where are your Maga hats whew
it'll be great look out look how
handsome this guy is
you think that you think they would do
the Rambo thing like they normally do
right you think that he'd be like oh you
know he just lays into him did you guys
speaking of laying into him did you guys
see uh uh Kid Rock this morning no what
what a video of a kid boy I'm really
interested in this hold on there's a
video of Kid Rock not because he's upset
about the fact he's upset at the fact
that Bud Light Anheuser-Busch has now
put
um
is this why Seb Gorka threw his Bud
Lights away yeah yeah they're all
they're all freaking out they're all
freaking out because they're all saying
oh this you know American Beer even
though Anheuser-Busch is owned by
[__] inbev they've been owned since
by inbev through a hostile takeover back
in 2010 wait wait wait are you saying
are you saying that the American
Beverage Company was bought by a foreign
company now it's not an American exactly
Stella or is it Stella or Heineken I
can't remember their parents I forget
which one usually one buys the other but
I know that the parent company the
overarching one I believe it's called
inbev which is a German company
so why why is he shooting the woke beer
I'm like okay because this is why you
guys don't want to miss Trump
decided to put
um they've made this lgbtq
initiative and they've put messages and
people that are from that community on
Bud Light whoa whoa whoa are you saying
that lgbtq people drink beer is that
what you're saying yep oh my God who you
you know you remember you remember
Bethany you remember Bethany Mandel
um the woman who couldn't say what what
woke was even though she wrote a book
about it yeah that she had a she was
upset yesterday because she was like oh
show me that your marketing department
doesn't know what your demographic is
and it's like the fact that you think
the only people that drink [__] Bud
Light are a bunch of bigots because
that's what you're saying you're saying
that the people who are unwilling to
drink this beer are people who do not
like Pro lgbtq Plus messaging that's
what you're saying you're saying that
the marketing department at Bud Light
doesn't understand the fact that the
real demographic is a bunch of racists
and the fact that you're upset [__]
KK Karen is because you are also racist
and you are the person who's trying to
push this anti-lgbtq messaging so Texas
Paul do you drink woke light I mean Bud
Light do you drink
you do not what what what what what
unwoke or woke beer do you drink because
we all have beers I drink Miller Lite I
drink Miller Light and and Coors Light
sorry sorry I mean I get it I I lived in
Milwaukee man I'm I'm a Miller man
myself I enjoy it I like I like a watery
Pilsner beer when I'm gonna drink
several beers I do when I'm gonna drink
several beers now if I'm just gonna sit
and enjoy a beer I'll drink a Guinness
but my you know my I'm half Irish okay I
love Guinness I do it's not because I'm
like ooh also hoity-toity and [__] I
just love Guinness I do I grew up
drinking that brown [__]
Killian's Irish Red you know if I'm
gonna drink a beer to enjoy a bear
I've got several go-to's but my good my
everyday beer if I'm working outside and
I'm drinking some beers while cutting
brush is Miller Lite I want Miller time
baby I I get it I get it again I lived
in Milwaukee where Miller is is King is
King but also when you're a college
student and you're like oh what can I
drink the most of for the least amount
of money Coors Light got those cool
Rocky Mountains got Miller Light
anything making it worse listen listen I
I I'm champagne beers we'll do the whole
thing so obviously there's mountain of
Anheuser beer everywhere in Missouri and
my favorite all-time favorite is natural
light it's like oh Natty light that's
yeah Nanny light is is Bud light's you
know red-headed step cousin right
um and in Missouri cousins can [__]
Arkansas too but mainly Missouri so
that's that's why I drink Natty life I
mean that that was the beer of choice
number one because it was cheap as [__]
a case of natural light for nothing back
then I don't know how much it costs now
I bought a case of natural light and a
lot I mean I will say as a college
student as a freshman or as a sophomore
you know trying to get you get access to
certain drinks right Natty lights like
top of the list right there it's up
there well here's the thing when I got
into my Keystone Light that's enough oh
my god oh all right how old I am man
does anybody remember wide mouth Mickeys
are you speaking foreign
yeah you could always buy the Mickeys it
was like a dollar a six-pack man we had
the generic [__] every once in a while
here we go here we go here we go there
he is he's walking into the courtroom
that's it yeah that face let play back
play back uh let's see if we can get it
back here
he is there's the
those are lawyers probably lawyers is
that taco peanut yeah
he does look like Boris Epstein let's
see if we can get the um there's Cyrus
Vance the last prosecutor so so that's
that's it folks that's all the [__]
you're gonna get [__] is you got
those five seconds that's in five it was
it five [__] it was definitely less than
30 seconds
um here it is here it is uh I believe so
yeah so here's the here we go here's the
lawyers yep there's Taco Pina Taco penis
yep there's one of them yeah that guy
can't keep his [__] mouth Boris that
is Boris isn't it
that seemed like it looks like Boris to
me I mean did I miss it again I guess he
needed somebody to hold his freaking
hand when he was saying see if you can
go pull the clip up on Twitter because
it's got to be out there somewhere on
Twitter already
I mean there it is here it is oh there
he is he's pissed off no waves no fist
pump no nothing not liking it
because here's the thing he just had to
go through the [__] arraignment
process so you're gonna tell me that
this guy actually enjoyed himself for
whatever the process entailed right
taking the fingerprints getting a mug
shot all of that jazz
look at that look he looked he looked
down the barrel of the gun and look at
everyone was like
I don't I'm not happy and he's not happy
he's not happy somebody somebody asked
where's Elena Haba dude Elena Haba
hasn't been on this case I don't think
she's ever been on this case uh there he
is there's the Stills sure he's so sad
sorry I mean I have to say listen when
when you do when you do get arraigned in
court on felony charges it is kind of a
[__] I'm not gonna lie I mean
you know well the thing is I mean shit's
weird it it reality sets in yeah before
before this moment before Donald Trump
came into the courtroom right or into
the the courthouse
it was all like the possibility of this
happening it was always like oh well it
could or it could not like I haven't
actually officially been indicted and I
haven't officially had to step foot
inside the courthouse
but when you look at this he's like oh
wow okay this is actually happening this
is this is that moment where you're like
oh [__] okay
I cannot officially go back and erase
this moment it is on the record in the
public purview everyone has seen me walk
in go to the courtroom and I will have
to walk out here's another screenshot
um Twitter is all a buzz right now with
this uh two seconds where he came in and
it looks like it looks like to me that
he needs his diaper changed if I'm gonna
be honest that's what it looks like I'm
hoping the Secret Service the other
thing too is I think he's afraid that
before this moment he was able
to argue his way out and say that it
wasn't it wasn't what everyone thinks it
or think it is right and he's now has to
know that
all of this [__] is going to officially
be on the record and I think that's kind
of the realization I'm not saying that
you know he has the ability to have
shame or embarrassment or feel those
things for the other crime that he's
committed whether it's Mar-A-Lago or Jan
six or you know Fulton County or
whatever but this is the first one that
is on public display for everyone to
watch this one is the this is the
breaking of the ice on this one and he
has to go through this potentially other
times and so now everyone's going to see
him in this vulnerable position and
everyone's gonna know whatever these 34
or more counts are against him
for what he did which we're gonna know
what the 34 counts are how many there
are how many are felonies what these
counts are very very soon can you keep
your eye on that see if there's a yeah I
don't know who who would have sociopaths
hate being held account
held to account sociopaths hate that
worse than anything I mean that's just
pure violence and rage in their heads
when you hold a sociopath accountable
for I mean think about it when has
Donald Trump ever been held accountable
for anything he's ever done I mean when
they took his hotels in Atlantic City
that was about it I mean even even the
election I mean he did nothing there was
no transition nothing he sat up in that
white house thinking that he was going
to keep that place I mean it was he
couldn't even handle losing the election
this has got to be just
eating him alive
oh yeah well here's here's a little bit
from uh Fox News Jonathan turley's take
on this let's listen to this show I got
I gotta oh my God I can't I can't wait
the the president is comfortable in
chaos it may be his element He tends to
go on
the question is whether he will rise
above it and seem more presidential to
bring what dogs
and to say instead this is a threat to
the presidency it's not just about me
he's not the [__] president he's not
the president are you [__] [__] who
is this but Jonathan Turley they need to
take his [__] constitutional law
license away from him are you [__]
kidding me what the [__] are you talking
about he's not the president won't be
present he's going to try but he won't
be because the American people don't
like this [__] we don't like him
we don't want him the only people who
want him are a small percentage of the
country who are deluded as [__] and then
they're [__] redheaded step cousin
the people who vote for Republicans no
matter what Bill Barr went on Fox News
this weekend and said he's a petulant
child and the reason why there's no
[__] way that bill Barr would ever
put him on the stand is because he can't
keep his [__] mouth shut and he can't
handle it he can't can't handle it he's
a [__] idiot he's a goddamn idiot and
then if you ask Bill Barr would you vote
for him he's like of course I'd vote for
him he's a republican like well they
they all say [__] man every one
of them will be like no well you know
I'm not gonna back Trump because Trump's
a loser and we only want to keep winning
we've lost you know 20 you know 2018
2020 2022 like we've lost so many times
and then when asked the question well
will you vote for him he's a nominee and
they don't say yes they say I'll vote
for whoever the nominee is in other
words they would vote for him because
he's Republican right that's that's what
that's what that means it's ridiculous
on its face it's stupid but that's what
we have is the party is stupid Texas
Paul we have the party of stupid
absolutely and that's why I always say
nobody gets a break nobody gets a break
there are no good Republicans none of
them they're already all sorry sons of
[__] because they all say oh [__]
what was his name when we were covering
the uh the January six hearings Tony
um the the
um Speaker of the House in Arizona
yeah Rusty Bowers they were harassing
his dying daughter mm-hmm
he just gave testimony that trumpers
were outside his house screaming so that
his dying daughter who was there to die
in his home could not have peace and at
the end of it they asked him will you
vote for him oh yeah I have I have I
have footage outside Trump Tower here it
looks like
um people are showing their love and
support oh yeah that's Chicago baby oh
yeah no this is a this is a very this is
a very popular picture in Chicago yeah
yeah it's a very popular picture in
Chicago and the reason why is because
the the bus tour goes right by and I I'm
taking the bus to her in Chicago it goes
right by Trump Tower in Chicago well you
also you also get the same tour when
you're if you if if anyone's in
you know unsolicited plug for for in
Chicago if you're ever in Chicago and
you like architecture or you like
getting a different route of the of the
city take the river architecture tour I
highly recommend it I'm a big fan I go
whenever I can and I'm from Chicago even
though I know the history but you go
along the river and you pass by it just
like the bus tour and uh they always
throw shade
um at the building and people you know
will throw up the middle finger as well
I got some breaking news I got some
breaking news news um here's some people
who aren't indicted today oh look at
that couple uh breaking news these two
speaking of Chicago
um these two are not being indicted or
arraigned today yeah he's actually
building his library right now something
that you probably won't see Trump ever
do will he be putting his presidential
records in that Library under Nara is
that what he'll be doing putting him in
his uh [__] basement somewhere I mean
it would seem like there's a protocol in
place like if you actually follow and
listen to Nara they might say Hey you
can have these records and you put them
here and we'll keep the other records
funny but we'll have them so that they
can be yeah I got more breaking news
here's here's a couple other people who
aren't indicted or arrested today
you know I loved when Trump went on
Hannity and was talking about selling
things back to the government you know
he was talking to me and you mentioned
Nixon yeah yeah and you know Nixon
actually wrote Memoirs what they bought
from Nixon was actually his own work
product where he put pen to paper it
wasn't the government's property that
the government bought back from Nixon it
was Nixon's own work product that they
bought do you think Donald Trump and his
freaking life ever put pen to paper and
wrote a damn sentence Beyond Big Mac
large fries two cokes you know I mean
really wait he wrote that much
come on dad you're giving him a lot of
yeah you're assuming a lot that he wrote
those things the other I mean like I
haven't seen him ever write a message
though he does have the I have I have an
official statement from Democrats all
around the world
um I like how Joe Biden never bakes for
his legal expenses I mean I'm just
saying the news is rolling in baby the
news is rolling yeah I feel like I need
to I need to share my FaceTime call
again
breaking news keeps rolling and I don't
mean to keep interrupting no no I mean
this is great breaking news I mean we're
fine you know again we don't know how
long he'll be in this courtroom here
right now maybe about 15-20 minutes I'd
I'd say that's probably that's probably
about it have you seen have you I I'm
I'm trying to keep track if there's if
the indictment the indictment's gonna
drop
um who who are you watching right um uh
Twitter feed I'm I'm going all over the
I'm going between Kyle yeah that's right
and I mean I'm trying to remember gotta
try Kyle Chaney see if he's yeah
um here is here's this is the first
person who is the first person not to
say that they will again but who's the
first person to get the actual uh order
that went to oh nope this is something
else never mind this is Jack Smith so
this is this is a official um
photography
um from the courtroom here you see uh
Taco penis here um now look how defeated
he looks yeah and then then a [__]
ain't that about a [__] that is [__]
he's all like look at his hair man he's
all like
you know that is one thing today is not
his his hair day man it's not happening
of all the days of all days to have a
good hair day today this would have been
it listen I'm telling you that is one
thing that probably terrifies him about
jail and being locked up and I bet
that's one way that they'll keep his gag
um gag in place like his attorney's like
look do you really want to try to do
your hair in a jail I don't they're not
we don't sell those things in commissary
okay like you can't get you can get
Ramen how long how long do you think it
takes him to do that that hairdo how
long I would say
you know I look it's an ongoing process
it has yeah yeah I I think probably as
much time as it takes for a drag queen
to get ready for a show right you've got
makeup you've got hair you've got an
outfit you've got everything and it
takes a lot of time because it's an art
right and I think Donald Trump the only
art of the deal that Donald Trump has is
the art of dealing with putting on
makeup and doing his hair during the day
well here you know that cheap bastard
that cheap bastard buys freaking Aqua
Net I mean that is a smell like your
grandma from the 80s you know he uses a
can and a half of that [__] in his hair
because he won't spend any more than
than I would love to know how much money
that Donald Trump spent of taxpayer
money
for his upkeep right like he had a per
he probably has a hair makeup person
right he doesn't do it himself you know
he's got products that need to be uh
purchased to maintain that leather face
and I want to know how much money that
was written off to be like personal
daily care or whatever the budget line
is to look at and be like is it more or
less than the amount of money we spent
to finance him going to his own Golf
Resorts right
that's what I want to know
so I'm looking to see if we have any new
updates and if we have the actual
indictment because that's that's really
what we're waiting on now because we
won't get footage inside the courtroom
of him being indicted or arraigned
excuse me on the indictment but um
that's the the one picture we got we'll
get a few of those probably right um as
the day goes along of him in the
courtroom before he is arraigned as they
start the proceedings but the thing that
I'm looking for the thing that I want
is I want the
uh I want the actual indictment to see
what these charges are and what they
aren't because I believe that's where
it's going to get to the heart of Maga
and how pissed off they're going to be
because I think these this indictment is
going to piss them off either way it
goes you know these are yeah 34 of the
same business charges and their felonies
um or if it's different charges and they
really don't know how to spend it
because they're going to keep talking
about hush money payments to porn stars
the reason why they do that Texas ball I
think the reason why they talk about
hush money payments to pornstars because
they know the left doesn't give a [__]
if someone pays hush money to a porn
star I don't like that doesn't that
doesn't phase me I'm not like oh wow so
you had sex with a porn star and you
want make sure people don't find out and
you pay them I actually don't think that
that's that big of a deal but it's not
about the actual payment that one
payment that's not what it's about it's
about all the crime that happened after
that payment that's that's what this
investigation is about and I think
that's what these charges are going to
show
I think I think people are still do care
about the fact that his wife was at home
with a five-month-old infant at the time
right you know I think they care about
that and I think that they care that he
broke the law it's you know it's like
John Edwards you know when he did I keep
going back to John Edwards his wife was
dying of freaking cancer and he's
fooling around on the damn campaign
trail with with uh reality or what's her
name real Hunter you know people didn't
dig that [__] man I mean it's people
yeah but Texas I got it I gotta hand it
back to you because I I I think I think
you're wrong I think the American people
don't give a [__] about that kind of
stuff I mean this guy is the guy who
weeks before he got he got elected
got a piece of film that's that he
bragged about sexually molesting women
talking about grabbing them by the [__]
the country went man like all the
Republicans like oh we can't have that
and they abandoned him and then the
country's like man we'll still vote for
him who gives a [__] right and the
Republic's like yeah you're right you
know you're right so I actually don't I
actually don't believe that they give a
[__] about the hush money Fame but they
don't care about porn stars well yeah I
mean if they did if they if they did
care you would find that more
evangelicals and Christians would say
whoa whoa whoa I mean like Tony and I
have been on these Twitter spaces lately
and there's one person in particular who
always makes such a point of being like
look you know I'm a Christian and like
yeah morally I don't accept what Donald
Trump did however with that being said
there's a big butt clause in there they
go look morally I don't accept what he
did but the things he did as president
or the things he will do as president
outweigh the moral corruption in of the
act that he did which is like if you
really did believe what you believed
really did follow Christ right
or believe that these sins that he's
committed were bad then you showing
support goes against what you believe
and I get the whole fact like you know
forgive your neighbor and all that
[__] but when they can
uh sorry I got another I've got another
uh photograph this may or may not be
edited from the uh I mean it looks
pretty crazy
I'm just trying to find some stills from
inside the courtroom sorry about that
you know though Tony I think that goes
back to you know I always rail about old
Chris Ruffo over at the Manhattan
Institute uh and in his line in the
salon I believe was a salon interview
where he said they were talking about
CRT and everything and he wants to
politicize every aspect of government
every everything because it's the
politics when once you make it political
you know you've got people that would
not put up with that [__] but
Republicans are fatally flawed in that
respect this is why I say both item both
sidism is [__] because people say
well uh you know the you get these right
Wingers are constantly saying well Joe
Biden did this and Joe Biden and
Democrats always say prove it if he did
something I will convict him myself
Republicans no once it's political once
it's political like you said right on
the bus
just filthy and as disgusting as can be
or or the meme you always see about him
mocking the reporter uh the handicapped
reporter and it always says this should
have been the end of it once you make it
political there is no Behavior a
republican will not accept as okay you
know look what we did to Al Franken
look what we did to Al Franken for
posing was somebody that he had joked
with forever they had made off-color
jokes with each other forever but a
picture came up of his
piss-poor Behavior
you know hovering his hands over this
woman's breast while she was asleep
we canceled that [__] so it's I
I have to say people care
Republicans don't Republicans don't give
a [__] about democracy Republicans don't
give a [__] about the rule of law they
don't give a [__] about decency they
sure as [__] don't give a [__] about
Christianity if Republicans cared about
Christianity the Christian Coalition
wouldn't exist
you know I mean it's just here here is
um I've got another photo here this is a
screenshot here sorry I'm I'm just I'm
trying to find some stuff here's Rachel
bittickoffer she says no one held the
door for him
um wow ain't that a better [__] uh can
you go to the the link I sent you so
yeah we've got uh
uh what are you an actual commentary
from uh looks like Scott McFarland from
Scott McFarland he's in from inside the
courtroom I don't know if he's waiting
in on the phone call or if he's was in
the I don't know exactly but he's on the
phone with CBS so if you want to roll
that back if you yeah and uh let me see
if I can yeah scats we always appreciate
Scott
[Music]
um
here is let's see let's pull up um he's
officially not guilty inside the
courtroom not
became
Focus no it's it's much closer to the
end
to be
troll this
is it is it the part where Scott's going
the police are getting
I say that because you have
but if you look at what some of us
former president as you'd imagine Nora
just surrounded by law enforcement not
just secret service but there is New
York police there is New York state
court security and there is
a group of police out in the hallway
monitoring activities here it says he's
inside the courthouse not in the
courtroom and the judge got a challenge
from the media organization to open this
up to phones and laptops into cameras
and the judge rejected all those motions
so all this is happening behind closed
doors with a feed a video and audio feed
going across the hallway to an overflow
room
Scott McFarland has been witnessing
Donald Trump inside that courtroom as
they read the criminal charges against
him Scott just so it looks like it looks
like he's he's inside the Overflow room
he's calling from
he answered immediately in a voice that
was noticeably louder and the attorneys
who were speaking here today and said
simply not guilty no adjectives before
it nothing after it just not guilty and
at this point they're running through
the procedures that will happen after
this arraignment ends there are going to
be certainly deadlines set for motions
for future hearings all that's happening
as I'm speaking to you Nora but the
bottom line here is 34 counts of the
same charge according to the clerk 34
counts falsifying business records in
the first degree there's more to gather
but let me just paint a picture for you
here Nora this is such a humble place
the 15th floor of this courthouse in
Manhattan looks like an old middle
school hallway that type of flooring
that type of wall it is sweltering
stuffy hot in here and in the courtroom
and all of this
looks like something out of the TV show
Night Court not something out of one of
the brands
limited camera access Scott McFarland
went there he'd asked for saying if
cameras might turn this into a
circus-like atmosphere or perhaps
sparing some of the images of a very
Meek and humble place okay so I want to
point something out here in Texas Paul
you you made this catch when they were
walking into the courtroom this this
here is oh sorry this here is Taco Pina
or taco penis as we've been calling him
in here is Boris Epstein that is bore
stepstein uh that at the very end of the
table Boris Epstein was on his 2016
campaign was a vital part of his 2020
he's the very vital part of the big lie
um he's been he's been the subject of
several subpoenas Lately by Jack Smith I
believe in the January 6th
um um trials now Boris here is a um a
complete piece of [__] as far as I'm
concerned in Moscow right born in Moscow
and I believe he is he is Donald Trump's
Russian Handler I believe that I can't
prove it but I believe that he is sorry
piece of [__] here he is inside the
courtroom Texas ball so if you're saying
that you're saying his Russian contact
is right here with him inside the
courtroom is that what you're saying
that yeah I I believe Boris Boris was
born in Moscow he's a Russian that's why
he's got the freaking name Boris you
know like Boris and Natasha you know
yeah from Rocky and Bullwinkle Boris you
know that's Boris and I and for years
this guy's been given a freaking pass
you know let's take a look at what his
what are his connections back to Russia
we know Trump's compromised I mean this
guy's standing right freaking next to
him and every time there's something
dirty going on down in Brazil or you
know anywhere that they're involved
freaking Boris is there
so um routine for children has it how it
started this morning and how it's going
there it is I mean how it started and
completely defeated I mean the photo
that hunched over like you don't have to
be a body like language expert to
understand that there are certain key
things like when you lock up your arms
or when you are hunched over or when you
can't make you know eye contact to
people there are certain body language
signs and this is one of them
hunched over right this is those moments
when you see him in those off those
meetings when he was in the White House
like hunched over when he didn't know
what was going on or he didn't really
have anything to add or he was
intimidated or he was you know defeated
right and this is that moment where he's
like the look on his face a dude who's
supposed to be the alpha male for the
Mega Nation this guy's sitting on a [__]
full diaper and unable to say anything
other than
not guilty or not not guilty but uh uh
that he that he pleaded uh yeah not that
he pleaded not guilty right well they
asked that the judge would ask how do
you plea yeah you would plead and he
said not guilty and it's amazing that he
was able to just say two words right he
was he was uh able to withhold himself
from saying anything more than just
those two words and the fact also to to
Scott McFarland like the fact that he's
in this courtroom that doesn't look like
the stereotypical or or the yeah of a
law and order right yeah the fact
because I've been in a courtroom like
this in LA to pay my [__] traffic
ticket okay well this is where you would
go to to handle those issues
um Patriot takes points out in this
picture is the Republican 2024 front
runner for the Republican ticket here in
court
um As Trump is being reigned now we we
now know because of Scott's reporting
that there's 34 charges of this uh the
fraudulent business and transaction it
seems like so now what evidence they
have of that will we will have to see in
trial
um and that's one thing that's going to
take a long time folks I I I'm gonna
have to because we're going to ramp it
up here in a few minutes but
um I have to tell you that that is one
thing that's going to piss you off here
for a while is that we're not going to
see the evidence of this and they're
going to make up all kinds of [__] all
kinds of [__] they're going to spread
all kinds of Lies that's what they do
they're Republicans and they're going to
continue to do it they're going to use
their entire media apparatus to do that
but what I'll ask you is to make sure to
follow the Tony Michaels podcast because
we will smash it up with a hammer every
single weekday Monday through Friday
noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific for
two full hours or three hours on a day
like this
um so subscribe to the YouTube channel
please like share this link also
download every single episode on Apple
Spotify and Google and don't forget to
go find pro-democracy content creators
everywhere you can one place is Texas
Paul's channel that link is down below
you just go to Real Texas ball.com and
you can find that you can also go to the
upwire.com is another channel that has
got some pro-democracy creators that are
creating content for you to for you to
look at and to know the truth and that's
just a simple fact of it yes do we have
fun telling the truth here of course we
do because the truth should be fun it
should be fun okay so wait there's it
looks like there's also a conspiracy
charge
is it whoa whoa whoa whoa can you pull
that up for me no it's almost like it's
almost like Tony Michaels was onto
something here just a little bit ago and
has been on to something so this is as
of a few seconds ago but I saw a
conspiracy uh people were talking about
I just wanted to make sure the
conspiracy appears to be the underlying
crime that makes these felony Chargers
uh connected so you've got 34 counts of
false fine business records and
conspiracy okay so so the counts not
only include this is from
Ed here breaking former president Donald
Trump just but Yelp not guilty Excuse Me
2 30 we wish pled not guilty to 34
counts of falsifying business records
and conspiracy the conspiracy appears to
be the underlying crime that makes this
felony charges so here's the thing and
this is what Maga is going to try to
confuse everyone with in the state of
New York
falsifying business records generally is
a misdemeanor unless unless those
falsified business records are trying to
cover a crime
if you are trying to falsify your
business records just to falsify them
that's a misdemeanor right if you're
using it to try to cover a crime it it
gets into the conspiracy
um realm and that's where the felony
charges come from so that is why if this
is a conspiracy and they charge them
with the conspiracy that is why this
will be a felony charge each one of
those falsified business records that
they tried to use to cover up a crime
and my guess is they uncovered these
with the [__] Trump organizations uh
trial and the discovery and the
prosecution of the Trump organization
that's where they found these records
and they used the testimony of the
witnesses of how this conspiracy worked
and they uncovered this conspiracy to
cover crimes with these falsifying of
business records that's what it sounds
like to me Texas Paul what do you got
there uh you know I'll try to make this
real quick you know people are screaming
on the right well Hillary didn't get
prosecuted all she got was a fine what
you're talking about there Tony the
difference is it's really simple
there the case with Hillary Clinton was
that she paid a law firm to pay Fusion
GPS to do opposition research she filed
documents with the government and you
sign you sign on the bottom line that
these these documents are true to the
best of your knowledge that that she
paid for legal services so they find her
in the Democratic party a hundred
thousand dollars because that wasn't
perfectly 100 accurate
right it wasn't a crime because the the
payment was on the books and it was to
the right people
but it was not to cover fully disclosed
that it was opposition research right
that much alone is just a crime what
Donald Trump did was he paid he had his
attorney
take out a mortgage to hide the money
where the money was coming from take out
a mortgage pay Stormy Daniels from that
mortgage that he just checked that he
just got then turned around and created
a payment system from his company
to pay him over 12 months over twice
what he paid Stormy Daniels plus a
handling fee was like four hundred
thousand dollars so there's there are
aggravating circumstances involved
because this never even made it to the
campaign books
this came out of his business right that
he paid him so yeah they're that this is
like what Hillary Clinton did which was
wrong and she got fined for
this is that on steroids because they
didn't not only did they not say we paid
this guy but they didn't even put it on
the campaign books
here's a couple more pictures from
inside the courtroom there this is from
Getty so um this is from the official
record of the courtroom that did that
the judge actually allowed a camera
inside to take pictures and this is the
Getty image Aaron has this here so I'll
retweet it uh he doesn't look happy
there at all I wonder if they got an
audio recording of him saying not guilty
that will eventually hear you know you
know what I mean like did they not
guilty not guilty I wouldn't be
surprised
but there's a part of me where when they
ask him like how do you play negos
guilty I mean uh not guilty like at
least if he accidentally says the 100
buttons laptop
yeah
where's Hunter where's Hunter he's
guilty where is he where's Hunter he's
at home Joe said he wants to meet me
behind the barn I would love that you
know where Hunter Biden is Hunter Biden
is at home right now naked doing blow
[__] hookers watching the Trump
arraignment on his laptop that's where
the [__] Hunter Biden is at this point
you [__] sour ass sons of [__] I
want to show you this reminds me of the
the back and forth here reminds me of a
clip I watched yesterday where someone I
think it was an attorney of trump or
someone defending Trump on Fox News had
a 40 inch slip let me see if I can find
that but before we before we go here if
I can
um because it's Priceless I know exactly
what you're looking for this is um this
is hilarious let me show you here this
is from Fox News
um see if you can catch what he calls
him at the end here the state court so
it's virtually impossible for him to
prove that that felony so if this is
such a tough case for him to Jake why is
he bringing it
well I I think there's no question about
it that he wants to humiliate president
fraud or president Trump
wait wait wait wait what was that again
what was that what was that you got to
do what was that on this maybe me put it
what was that that he wants to humiliate
president fraud or president Trump and
we had have we had a president Frederick
fraud before is that is that I I don't I
don't know but I don't know I don't know
it's officially on the record here in an
interview so I guess we do have a
president or at least a former president
fraud well let me let me ask you guys he
says this is going to be really hard to
prove almost impossible well didn't they
prove it against Michael Cohen didn't
Michael go to prison is Michael Cohen
not cooperating saying he asked me to do
it uh you know here's where the they
found the money because Michael Cohen
said look here's the mortgage here's
where they paid me here's the accounts
they came out of this one's not really
freaking hard to prove this is one
literally like I said open the books and
point at the line I mean you know you
know what else on the conspiracy side
that I think is significant is that they
brought in uh pecker from the national
Inquirer and we know that we know that
pecker was out there trying to float
these stories that he would buy these
stories from these people to try to find
them to try to Drudge them up but who
would say something I'm not so sure that
that's not part of the conspiracy here
folks
right right well exactly so I'm not I'm
not so sure that there isn't this big
huge way that Michael Cohen and these
others used to smoke out these people
who would say something or do something
that Donald Trump didn't want them to do
and they were committing crime and
conspiracy to try to cover this up and
they were using these these payments in
a way
and and and uh defrauding uh the the
state of New York by making fraudulent
business records to cover a crime so we
will see but don't go anywhere because
tomorrow tomorrow you have to come back
here same time same place I'm telling
you noon Eastern 11 Central nine Pacific
on YouTube Twitter and twitch You're
Gonna Want to subscribe right now don't
miss it set the Bell notification
tomorrow we're going to have former
Senator former Federal prosecutor Doug
Jones on the show we're also going to
have my favorite political strategist Dr
Rachel bidikoffer on the show we got a
big show tomorrow to go through this
Trump arraignment and I'm so happy that
Texas Paul joined us today again his
link is down in in the description
realtexaspaul.com that's
realtexasfall.com don't miss his show on
Sundays also don't forget to go to what
was that show.com that's what was
thatshow.com check out what Gabe's doing
over on his patreon why you're on
patreon folks don't forget to check out
my patreon it's patreon on.com the Tony
Michaels that's how we get our monetary
support here on the show because this
show is live every single day and it's
free for you to watch we got extra
content over there on patreon so go
check out our patreons it's patreon.com
see Tony Michaels or patreon.com I am
Gabe Sanchez everyone I'm so glad you
stuck around we we went over like we're
almost at 1500 likes today this is a
huge broadcast this is a three plus hour
show here that was awesome um well we
really appreciate you guys sticking
around for us we'll break down any news
that happens tonight at Mar-A-Lago or
any statements or any kind of clips that
come out we'll be doing it tomorrow
we'll get Doug Jones former Senator Doug
Jones will get his his legal take on it
we'll get Rachel's political take on it
we're gonna be here tomorrow same time
same place
Surf's Up [__] you've been
listening to the Tony Michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events and political news no rules No
Boundaries I think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] them
foreign
[Music]